ON EDUCATION TO ORDER. AND I
WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL, TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WHEN THE
OTHER MEMBERS FORMALLY ARRIVE,
THIS IS THE FIFTH HEARING OF THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE. NUMBER ONE
ON EDUCATION. AND WILL COVER
SOME CROSSOVER ISSUES TO
KINDERGAR THROUGH 12 AND HIGHER
EDUCATION. THERE ARE SEVEN ITEMS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA, THESE MIGHT
NOT BE THE HIGHEST PROFILE ITEMS
COMPARED TO DOING PROPOSITION 98
AND èC AND STUDENT AID AND SOME
OF THE OTHER ONES, BUT WE MAKE
IT A POINT TO AIR EVERY SINGLE
ISSUE SO THAT IT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED ALONG THE WAY, AND WE
CAN TAKE INPUT AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE FEED IT INTO THE MAY
REVISE AND TO THE DELIBERATIONS
BETWEEN THE HOUSES. AND AS
YOU'LL SEE, IF YOU'VE SEEN THE
AGENDA FOR THE LAST FEW ITEMS,
DO FIT TOGETHER IN TERMS OF
TEACHER SHORTAGES, CREDENTIALING
AND, EXPEDITING THE PROCESS AND
OTHER THINGS. EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE THEM LISTED OUT AS
INDIVIDUAL ITEMS IN THE HEARING.
AND SO, WE WILL GO THROUGH EACH
OF THE SEVEN ITEMS AND THEN WE
WILL DO PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER THE
SEVEN ITEMS. AND SO LET ME
REMIND EVERYBODY THAT IF YOU,
HAVE COMMENTS AND YOU'RE
WATCHING THIS AND NOT ABLE TO BE
HERE, WE WELCOME THE COMMENTS,
AT THE WEBSITE OR AT THE TO CARE
OF THE SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND SO WHILE NOW UNDER THE RULES
COMPARED TO WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
PANDEMIC AND POST-PANDEMIC, WE
DON'T ALLOW TELEPHONE TESTIMONY,
WE DO LIKE TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
KNOW THAT THEY CAN WRITE AND
PARTICIPATE THROUGH THE WEBSITE.
IF THEY CANNOT BE AT THE HEARING
IN PERSON TO OFFER A COMMENTS AT
THE END OF THE SESSION. SO WITH
THAT, WE WILL MOVE TO ISSUE
NUMBER ONE, THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE GUIDANCE INITIATIVE. AND
WE HAVE MELISSA NG FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, TESSA
DEROY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE GUIDANCE INITIATIVE, AND
MADISON JABLONSKI, SHEFFIELD
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION, AND JACKIE BAROCIO
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AND WE WILL GO IN THAT
ORDER. AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
MICROPHONE THAT PEOPLE ARE
HAVING PROBLEMS WITH LAST WEEK
HAS BEEN FIXED. AND THE TROUBLE
IS, IS APPARENTLY PEOPLE WERE
TURNING IT OFF, WHEN THEY
THOUGHT THEY WERE TURNING IT ON
AND IT DIDN'T LOOK LIKE IT
WORKED. SO WE WILL WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S A FUNCTIONAL
MICROPHONE AS WE GO THROUGH THE
HEARING. SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING. CAN YOU HEAR ME?
IT'S ON. IS IT ON OKAY. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIR MELISSA
NG WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I'LL BE PRESENTING ON
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
GUIDANCE INITIATIVE, OR CCI. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES AN
INCREASE OF 5.084 MILLION.
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND FOR
KGI TO CONTINUE SCALING ITS
SERVICES AS PART OF ITS ROLE AS
THE OPERATIONAL TOOL OF THE
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM,
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL BE
USED TO FOR INCREASED PERSONNEL
COSTS AND TO MEET THE RISING
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS. AS KGI
CONTINUES TO SCALE, KGI IS
ENTERING YEAR THREE OF A PLANNED
FIVE YEAR SCALING PROCESS IN
WHICH IT WILL EXPAND PROVISIONS
OF ITS TOOLS AND SERVICES TO ALL
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
SERVING STUDENTS GRADES SIX
THROUGH 12. THIS REQUEST IS IN
LINE WITH PREVIOUS PROJECTIONS
FOR SCALING, AND WILL ENSURE KGI
HAS THE RESOURCES TO CONTINUE
ADDING PARTNER DISTRICTS,
INTEGRATE WITH HIGHER EDUCATION
APPLICATIONS, AND DEVELOP
COLLEGE AND CAREER PLANNING
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGY TO BETTER
SERVE STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS.
CURRENTLY, KGI IS PARTNERED WITH
A LITTLE OVER HALF OF THE
ELIGIBLE DISTRICTS, WITH MANY
DISTRICTS POTENTIALLY FACING
GREATER BARRIERS TO ENTRY. THE
INCREASE PROPOSED IN GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WILL BRING THE TOTAL
ONGOING APPROPRIATION TO 23.7
MILLION. WITH THIS INCREASE, WE
BELIEVE KGI IS AT THE LIMIT FOR
COST FOR SCALING, BARRING
INFLATION OR OTHER UNFORESEEN
FACTORS, AND WE WOULD NOT
ANTICIPATE FUTURE MAJOR FUNDING
INCREASES, ESPECIALLY SINCE
CERTAIN INCREASES LIKE VENDOR
COSTS, COULD BE OFFSET BY
IMPROVED INTERNAL OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES. WHEN KGI IS AT
SCALE, KGI IS PURPOSE AND
FUNCTION ARE CODIFIED IN
EDUCATION CODE SECTION 60900.5,
AND THIS BUDGET REQUEST IS ON
TRACK WITH EARLY PROJECTIONS FOR
THE COST OF FULLY SCALE. THIS
WORK STATEWIDE. KGI IS ALSO
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE TRANSCRIPT
INFORMED ACCOUNTS TO ALL NINTH
THROUGH 12TH GRADE STUDENTS BY
JUNE 2026, WHICH IS THE END OF
PHASE ONE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CRADLE TO CAREER LEGISLATION. SO
THE AGENDA DOES A GOOD JOB OF
LAYING OUT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS, INCLUDING TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. SO I WON'T GO
INTO THE DETAILS TO DESCRIBE
EACH AMENDMENT. BUT OVERALL, THE
PURPOSE OF A MAJORITY OF THE
AMENDMENTS IS TO HELP FACILITATE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
TRANSITION. TRANSCRIPT INFORMED
PARTNER ACCOUNTS FOR ALL NINTH
TO 12TH GRADE STUDENTS AND TO
HELP ENSURE THAT STUDENT RECORDS
ARE ACCURATELY RECORDED AND
STUDENTS GET CREDIT FOR THE
COURSES THEY COMPLETE. THIS
INCLUDES REQUIRING LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO ENTER A
DATA SHARING AGREEMENT WITH KGI
BY JANUARY 1ST, 2026. AND
STANDARDIZING A COMMON STRUCTURE
TO DATA ELEMENTS THAT ARE
REPORTED TO KGI TO STREAMLINE
WAYS OF SUBMITTING DATA AND
REDUCE THE NEED TO CLEAN DATA,
AND TO STORE AND REPORT DATA
ELEMENTS IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
TRANSCRIPT AND STUDENT RECORD
PORTABILITY STANDARD. THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. AND I ALSO
HAVE WITH ME, TESSA DEBROY FROM
KGI, TO ANSWER ANY PROGRAMMATIC
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON THESE
KGI PROPOSALS. OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND YOU DON'T WANT TO
MAKE A PRESENTATION. YOU'LL JUST
BE PRESENT FOR US FOR THINGS.
WELL, BEFORE WE GET TO THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION, WE'RE
GOING TO PAUSE AND HAVE A CALL
OF THE ROLE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SENATOR LAIRD HERE,
SENATOR LAIRD HERE. SENATOR MINH
, SENATOR WILK PRESENT. SENATOR
WILK PRESENT. OKAY WITH ONE
PERSON HERE AND ONE PERSON
PRESENT, WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. MADISON.
SHEFFIELD IS CALIFORNIA STUDENT
COMMISSION. ALSO. NO COMMENTS,
BUT HAPPY TO BE HERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY. THANK YOU. AND
THEN WE'LL MOVE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
JACKIE BAROCIO LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE WITH REGARDS TO
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE, IT
SEEMS LIKE THE PROPOSED SYSTEM
CHANGES MAY MAKE IT EASIER FOR
DISTRICTS, ESPECIALLY SMALL
DISTRICTS, TO PARTNER WITH KGI.
BUT IN OUR ANALYSIS AND IT'S
INCLUDED IN YOUR AGENDA, WE JUST
FLAGGED THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER ANY POTENTIAL
WORKLOAD IMPLICATIONS ON
DISTRICTS OR OTHER STATE
ENTITIES. AND THEN WITH REGARDS
TO THE PROPOSED FUNDING
AUGMENTATION, AGAIN, GIVEN THE
PROPOSITION 98 SHORTFALL THAT
WE'VE DISCUSSED IN DETAILS IN
PRIOR HEARINGS, WE'RE JUST
RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT ANY NEW
AUGMENTATIONS. AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT, REJECTING THE AUGMENTATION
WOULD RESULT IN DELAYS IN
STATUTORY REQUIRED ACTIVITIES,
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO JUST
PUSH OUT THOSE IMPLEMENTATION
DATES, WE WOULD FLAG THAT ONE
POTENTIAL BUDGET SOLUTION,
WITHIN KGI IS TO THE EXTENT
THAT, COSTS COME IN LOWER IN THE
CURRENT YEAR, IN 23, 24, JUST
USING THOSE CARRYOVER FUNDS TO
FURTHER OFFSET BASELINE COSTS IN
24, 25, LAST YEAR, IN 2223,
THERE WERE SOME CARRYOVER FUNDS
OF AROUND $3 MILLION. SO IF THAT
WERE TO OCCUR AGAIN, JUST
PROACTIVELY SCORING THE
CARRYOVER AND REDUCING BASELINE
COSTS IN 2425. AND DOES THAT
COMPLETE YOUR COMMENTS? YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, THEN I HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND I'LL
SEE IF I DEFER TO YOU, SIR.
OKAY. PLEASE NOTE FOR THE RECORD
, SENATOR WILK DEFERRED TO ME
AND, YES, BUT I HOPE IT'S A
PATTERN. THE ONE THING I WANTED
TO ASK IS, IS OUR AGENDA IS
REALLY CLEAR ON THE NUMBERS THAT
WE HAVE MOVED TO, BUT IT'S CLEAR
THAT THERE'S A BUNCH OF
DISTRICTS THAT AREN'T YET
PARTNERING. SO TO SPEAK, TO. I
DON'T KNOW WHO'S BETTER. MAYBE
THE, THE, KGI SPEAK TO WHO
HASN'T DONE IT YET, WHAT YOUR
EXPECTATION IS AND HOW THAT FITS
TO SORT OF THE PROGRAM COSTS
AND, AND MAYBE WHETHER IT FITS
TO OTHER THINGS SUCH AS THE
SMALLER SCHOOL DISTRICTS NOT
HAVING THE CAPACITY. I WAS
CURIOUS AS TO WHY PEOPLE HAVEN'T
JOINED US YET. YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION, SO THE
REASON THAT LARGELY WHERE WE ARE
SEEING GAPS IN THE STATE AT THIS
POINT IS IN THE NORTH STATE AND
THE EASTERN SIERRAS, OBVIOUSLY,
THOSE ARE DISTRICTS WITH MUCH
SMALLER ENROLLMENT AND FEWER
STAFF. SO IT'S A PARTS OF THE
STATE WHERE IT'S DIFFICULT TO
IMPLEMENT MANY THINGS, ONE OF
THE NICE THINGS ABOUT THE WORK
THAT WE DO AND THE PROPOSED
STRATEGY THAT WE'RE PIVOTING TO,
IS THAT THERE ARE ESSENTIALLY
SIX PRIVATE COMPANIES THAT THAT
MANAGE STUDENT INFORMATION
SYSTEMS FOR ALL OF THE DISTRICTS
IN THE STATE. RIGHT. SO THESE
ARE THE SYSTEMS WHERE ALL THE
RECORDS ARE KEPT ABOUT
ATTENDANCE, ABOUT COURSES AND
GRADES, ABOUT, VACCINATION. ALL
OF THE INFORMATION. RIGHT. SO
UNLIKE MANY THINGS THAT ARE
DIFFICULT TO IMPLEMENT IN THESE
SMALLER DISTRICTS, IN THIS WORK,
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
THREE PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS IN THE STATE TO
ESTABLISH THE FIRST EVER
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
TRANSCRIPT STANDARD. SO IT'S A
SET OF RULES ABOUT HOW STUDENT
RECORDS SHOULD BE CAPTURED,
STORED AND TRANSMITTED ACROSS
SYSTEMS TO ALLEVIATE THE BURDEN
ON STUDENTS AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE HIGHER ED SYSTEMS HAVE
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT THINGS LIKE
ADMISSION AND PLACEMENT,
FINANCIAL AID, AND SO THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE IS ABOUT
ENSURING THAT THE, THE PRIVATE
SECTOR STUDENT INFORMATION
SYSTEM PROVIDERS COMPLY WITH
THAT STANDARD, MEANING THAT THEY
CREATE ACTUAL DATA FIELDS WHERE
INFORMATION CAN BE STORED IN A
WAY THAT BENEFITS STUDENTS AS
THEY'RE TRYING TO APPLY TO
HIGHER EDUCATION. AND GET CREDIT
FOR THINGS LIKE A THROUGH G
COURSES THAT THEY'VE TAKEN IN
OTHER DISTRICTS, FOR EXAMPLE,
WHICH RIGHT NOW CANNOT BE STORED
OR DUAL ENROLLMENT COURSES THAT
THEY TOOK DURING HIGH SCHOOL,
BUT THAT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT,
THERE ISN'T UNIFORMITY IN HOW
THE STUDENT INFORMATION SYSTEMS
ARE CAPTURING THAT RIGHT NOW.
AND SO IT'S MAKING IT'S CREATING
CHAOS AROUND HOW STUDENTS ARE OR
ARE NOT GETTING CREDIT FOR THE
COURSEWORK THAT THEY'VE
COMPLETED. SO A LOT OF THE
LANGUAGE IS ABOUT, ENSURING THAT
THOSE SYSTEMS, THOSE STUDENT
INFORMATION SYSTEM VENDORS
COMPLY WITH THE STANDARD AND
THEN BUILD OUT WHAT'S CALLED AN
ADVANCED PROGRAMING INTERFACE,
WHICH IS JUST A REAL TIME DATA
EXCHANGE. IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THEY CAN DO READILY BECAUSE
THEY'RE TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES
THAT DISTRICTS CANNOT DO. RIGHT.
SO HISTORICALLY, WHAT YOU WILL
SEE IN TERMS OF OUR GROWTH IN
OUR SCALE HAS BEEN THERE WAS A
WHOLE BUNCH OF EARLY ADOPTER
DISTRICTS, MOST DISTRICTS THAT
SERVE A MORE THAN 5000 STUDENTS
AT THIS POINT ARE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH US, BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE
DISTRICTS THAT TEND TO HAVE
DEDICATED DATA AND TECHNOLOGY
STAFF WHO HAVE ENOUGH
SOPHISTICATION ON HOW TO
GENERATE THE QUERIES THAT WE
NEED IN ORDER FOR THEM TO UPLOAD
DATA TO US. I WILL SAY WHEN
THERE IS TURNOVER AND THERE'S A
LOT RIGHT NOW, WE DO GO THROUGH
PERIODS WHERE THERE WAS ONE
PERSON IN A DISTRICT WHO KNEW
HOW TO DO THAT, AND NOW THEY
DON'T ANYMORE. SO BY
SYSTEMATIZING THIS THROUGH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR SYSTEMS THAT THEY
PURCHASE, IT ACTUALLY WILL MAKE
SURE WE HAVE CONTINUOUS DATA
FROM ALL DISTRICTS, NOT JUST
FROM THE THING. LET ME GO INTO
THE TWO OTHER ISSUES, WHICH IS
CAPACITY AND MONEY. BUT BUT,
GIVEN WHAT YOU DESCRIBED, IT
SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S REALLY HARD
FOR A RURAL DISTRICT TO HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DO THAT. AM I
MISSING THAT OR DO THEY CONTRACT
WITH THIS COMPANY AND THEY DO
IT? YES. SO THE COMPANIES THEY
ALREADY HAVE THESE CONTRACTS
WITH, THE COMPANIES, THEY THEY
EVERY DISTRICT HAS SOME KIND OF
A STUDENT INFORMATION SYSTEM.
ONLY LOS ANGELES AND FRESNO USE
HOMEGROWN SYSTEMS. EVERY OTHER
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY HAS
SOME FORM OF STUDENT INFORMATION
SYSTEM. AND THIS COMES FROM
THEIR LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA MONEY AS PART OF GENERAL
OPERATIONS. I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
HOW EVERY DISTRICT FUNDS IT
BECAUSE THEY MAY USE DIFFERENT
SOURCES, BUT YES, IT IS PART OF
THEIR USE. THEIR ADA AND THEIR
LCAP, THEIR, THEIR LOCAL
CONTROL. SO THAT IF SOME OF
THESE RURAL DISTRICTS HAVE,
STUDENT INFORMATION SYSTEMS THAT
ARE COMPATIBLE WITH JUST DOING
THIS, THEN IT'S NOT AN
ADDITIONAL COST. IT ACTUALLY
REDUCES, IT'S NO, NO ADDITIONAL
COST. AND THEY ALL HAVE THEM. SO
THERE IS NO ADDITIONAL COST. THE
WORKLOAD ACTUALLY GETS REDUCED.
AND THE BARRIER TO ENTRY GETS
REDUCED. SO RIGHT NOW WHAT YOU
HAVE IS STAFF IN DISTRICTS WHO
GENERATE FILES AND UPLOAD THEM
TO US. SOME HAVE AUTOMATED THAT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF SOPHISTICATION OF HOW
TO DO THAT. SOME HAVE TO
MANUALLY PULL IT AS OFTEN AS
THEY'RE UPLOADING, WHICH IS
GENERALLY SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
WEEKLY AND ONCE A MONTH. THE IN
THIS IN THIS SHIFT IN STRATEGY,
WHEN ALL OF THESE STUDENT
INFORMATION SYSTEMS CAN DO THIS
IN AN AUTOMATED FASHION, IT IS A
ONE TIME SETUP THAT I COULD DO.
AND I'M NOT A TECHNOLOGY PERSON
WHERE YOU WOULD LITERALLY GO IN
AND SAY, HERE ARE THE DATA
ELEMENTS THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
THESE STUDENT TRANSCRIPT
RECORDS. YES, PLEASE SEND THIS.
NO, PLEASE DON'T SEND THAT BY
CHECKBOX. AND THEN HANDS OFF.
AND THE TECHNOLOGY JUST TALKS TO
EACH OTHER, WHICH, AGAIN MAKES
IT A LOT EASIER ON THE DISTRICTS
, ALSO MAKES IT EASIER ON MY
STAFF. AND THE ONE QUESTION I
WOULD HAVE IS A FOLLOW UP TO
THAT IS DO THE DISTRICTS KNOW,
DO THEY UNDERSTAND? DO THESE
SMALL DISTRICTS UNDERSTAND WHAT
IT WOULD TAKE TO DO THIS? AND
BECAUSE IF THAT'S WHERE THE
PEOPLE HAVEN'T BEEN SIGNING UP,
IT MAKES AN ODD YOU REPRESENT
THAT IT MIGHT SAVE THE MONEY. IT
LEADS ME TO BELIEVE THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S TRUE,
WELL, WE'RE NOT THERE YET,
RIGHT? SO WE'RE ON THE FRONT END
OF CREATING THE INTEGRATIONS
THAT WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
THEM TO SIGN UP. SO THERE'S WORK
TO BE DONE TO MAKE THAT POSSIBLE
. SO, WE ARE BEGINNING THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE STUDENT
INFORMATION VENDORS, BUT THEY'RE
NOT ALL GOING TO DO IT ON THE
NATURAL. IT IS NOT REQUIRED OF
THEM, THEN IT'S NOT GOING TO
RISE TO THE TOP OF THEIR
PRIORITY LIST FOR DEVELOPMENT,
WHICH IS WHY WHY WE'RE
REQUESTING THAT IT BECOME A
REQUIREMENT OF DOING BUSINESS
WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA IS THEIR ABILITY TO
COMPLY WITH THIS SET OF
STANDARDS, THE DISTRICTS THAT WE
HAVE MET WITH THE SMALL SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
TALKED IT THROUGH WITH THEM. WE
TALK WITH A LOT OF SMALL
DISTRICTS WHO, I MEAN, SOME OF
THEM ARE MOVING INTO THE SYSTEM
IRRESPECTIVE BECAUSE THEY ARE
ABLE TO DO THE LIFT ON THE DATA
THAT THEY NEED TO DO. OUR
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN THAT THE
DISTRICTS THAT WERE NOT YET
PARTNERED WITH ARE DISTRICTS
WHERE THERE'S LITERALLY NO ONE
WHO IS DEDICATED TO COLLEGE AND
CAREER, SO THEY DON'T SHOW UP IN
THE SAME PLACES WHERE ALL THE
OTHER DISTRICTS GATHER TO TALK
ABOUT THOSE ISSUES, AND THAT'S
WHY THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
AND LET ME ASK, BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ADDITIONAL
MONEY, WHAT CAN BE DONE, GIVEN
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH
THE CURRENT MONEY AND WHAT WOULD
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL MONEY TO DO
AS WE SCALE THIS UP. SO THE
BUDGET PROPOSES 5 MILLION FOR
KGI TO CONTINUE THIS WORK, TO
KIND OF REACH OUT TO THESE 5
MILLION ABOVE WHERE IT IS NOW OR
OR CONTINUING 5 MILLION ONGOING,
5 MILLION TO. BUT IT'S ALREADY
ONGOING OR THIS ESTABLISHES 5
MILLION THAT'S NEVER BEEN FUNDED
BEFORE. THAT THEN BECOMES
ONGOING ADDITIONAL 5 MILLION.
OKAY. THANK YOU. THE, WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
POINTED TO, WE WILL HAVE CARRY
FORWARD AT THE END OF THIS YEAR.
SO I ACTUALLY, WE DON'T NEED THE
FULL 5 MILLION ANY THAT WE HAD
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED, I CAN RUN
ADDITIONAL PROJECTIONS, BUT
WE'RE RIGHT NOW LOOKING AT ABOUT
A $3 MILLION CARRY FORWARD. I'M
CONCERNED THAT EVERYBODY'S GOING
TO BE INTERESTED IN THAT. I KNOW
THEY WILL, BUT BUT BUT BUT THEN
THE OTHER QUESTION IS, IS YOU DO
THE 3 MILLION OAN ASKED FOR
FIVE. SO IT'S 2 MILLION MORE.
WHAT DOESN'T HAPPEN IF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
RECOMMENDATION WERE ADOPTED,
THAT WE NOT DO A NEW ADDITIONAL
THING? WHAT IS MISSING BY NOT
GETTING THAT $2 MILLION THAT
WOULD BE ADDED TO THE CARRYOVER?
I THINK, AS LAO POINTED OUT,
THERE MIGHT BE A NEED TO KIND OF
DELAY THE, THE REQUIREMENTS AND
STATUTE BECAUSE THERE IS A
TIMELINE FOR WHEN THESE PARTNER,
ACCOUNTS NEED TO BE ONLINE AND
IT'S A 2026, BUT I AM I TO
DEDUCE FROM THAT ANSWER THAT THE
THING THAT WE WOULDN'T GET IS
GET IT ON TIME AND WE WOULD HAVE
TO DELAY IT. IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING? I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
IF WE IS TO CARRY OVER TOWARD
THE 5 MILLION AND WE DON'T DO
THE 2 MILLION THAT ARE ON TOP OF
IT, WHAT DO WE LOSE? THAT'S WHAT
I'M TRYING TO GET. CAN I MAY I,
THE POLICY, THE POLICY CHANGES,
THE ADJUSTMENTS THAT ARE
PROPOSED, LIKE PUTTING THESE
REQUIREMENTS ON THE STUDENT
INFORMATION SYSTEM VENDORS THAT
ACTUALLY WILL, WILL SAVE MONEY,
IN TERMS OF OUR OPERATIONS, IT
BUILDS EFFICIENCIES FOR US THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO, TO ACTUALLY
OPERATE WITH A LITTLE BIT LESS
MONEY THAN WE OTHERWISE WOULD.
NOT TILL THE FUTURE YEAR.
CORRECT. IT WILL TAKE A COUPLE
OF YEARS, BUT THAT 2 MILLION
WAITING FOR THIS, I UNDERSTAND.
YEAH BUDGETARY MYOPIC FASHION.
YEAH. NO I UNDERSTAND AND SO I
CAN HAPPILY RUN ADDITIONAL
PROJECTIONS AND PROVIDE THEM TO
STAFF, WITH A TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION IN DETAIL. THEN LET ME
ASK THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST IF
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT ON
THE DISCUSSION WE'VE BEEN HAVING
HERE. I THINK WE NOTED THAT TO
THE EXTENT IT DOES GET IN THE
WAY OF JUST THE TIMING OF
CERTAIN ACTIVITIES BEING
ACHIEVED, DELAYING THOSE IN
STATUTE. BUT, THE CONVERSATION
AROUND THE TRAILER BILL, AT
LEAST TO THE EXTENT OF, ADOPTING
THOSE STANDARDS, IN THEORY,
THOSE AREN'T NECESSARILY, HAVE
COST ASSOCIATED WITH IT BECAUSE
IT WOULD BE AN EXPECTATION
PLACED OFF ON THE PRIVATE
VENDORS TO MODERNIZE THEIR
SYSTEMS TO COMPLY WITH THAT. AND
THAT WOULD BE A STEP IN THE
DIRECTION, AND A STEP NEEDED TO
COMPLY WITH THOSE, LIKE OVERALL
STATE GOALS. SO, THERE IS THAT
ABILITY TO ADOPT THE TBL CHANGE,
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THAT'S THE
FIRST STEP IN THE PROCESS USING
ANY CARRYOVER FUNDS. IF THE
LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO FOR THAT
PARTIAL AUGMENTATION, AND THEN
REVISITING, OKAY, AFTER WE ADOPT
THAT FIRST STAGE NEXT YEAR, COME
BACK. WHAT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED? OR HAS THAT ADOPTING
THE STANDARDS ALREADY FREED UP
INTERNAL CAPACITY WHERE THAT $2
MILLION IS NO LONGER NEEDED?
OKAY. THANK YOU. LET ME ASK MY
COLLEAGUES AGAIN IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS. I'M THEN LET
ME SORT OF CLOSE BY SAYING THIS
HAS BEEN A GOOD DISCUSSION. I
THINK IT IS AIRED IT OUT IN A
WAY THAT BETWEEN NOW AND MAY
15TH OR MAYBE JUNE 15TH, WE KNOW
THE DISCUSSION WE NEED TO HAVE
AND THERE'S WAYS TO DO SOME OF
THIS THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE COST.
THERE MIGHT BE A CARRYOVER
THAT'S AN ISSUE. AND THEN
THERE'S A DECISION ABOUT WHETHER
WE GO OVER THE CARRYOVER AND
WHAT GETS LOST IN THE PROCESS.
BUT I THINK THAT THERE'S A
PUZZLE HERE THAT CAN BE PIECED
TOGETHER. SO I WOULD THANK
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR, FOR THEIR
COMMENTS AND, AND FEEL LIKE WE
HAVE A PATH FOR DISCUSSIONS FOR
THE NEXT PERIOD OF TIME. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THEN WE'LL
MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO, MATH
CURRICULUM, PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT, WE HAVE MEGAN SABA
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
CHERYL COTTON FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND I
NOTE THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST DID NOT SWITCH OUT. SO,
WE KNOW WHO WILL BE THERE. AND
LET'S, GO IN THAT ORDER. SO WHEN
YOU'RE READY, LET'S BEGIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, MEGAN SABA,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, I'LL
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THIS
PROPOSAL. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES 20,000,001 TIME
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND FOR
ONE OR MORE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION, OR A CONSORTIA OF
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO
PARTNER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MATHEMATICS PROJECT TO DEVELOP
AND DELIVER TRAINING, INCLUDING
TRAINING FOR MATHEMATICS COACHES
ALIGNED WITH THE 2023 CALIFORNIA
MATH FRAMEWORK, THIS LANGUAGE
ALLOWS THE GRANTEE TO PARTNER
WITH OTHER WELL QUALIFIED
ENTITIES. IN ADDITION TO THE
CALIFORNIA MATH PROJECT, THE
FUNDS WOULD BE AVAILABLE THROUGH
JUNE 2028. THAT CONCLUDES MY
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. IN 2023, THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION ADOPTED A NEW
MATHEMATICS FRAMEWORK TO HELP
EDUCATORS ALIGN CLASSROOM
TEACHING WITH CALIFORNIA'S
MATHEMATICS LEARNING STANDARDS
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FOR EDUCATORS IN ALIGNING THE
MATHEMATICS INSTRUCTION WITH THE
NEW FRAMEWORK. THIS PROJECT AIMS
TO CREATE TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
ASSISTANCE FOR MATH TEACHERS TO
EFFECTIVELY DELIVER HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTION. THE PROPOSED BUDGET
LANGUAGE IS IN ALIGNMENT WITH
SENATE BILL 1115, AUTHORED BY
SENATOR LIMÓN AND SPONSORED BY
STATE SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND,
WHICH AUTHORIZES THE CDE TO
CREATE PARTNERSHIPS TO PROVIDE
TARGETED, COHESIVE PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING FOR ALL TEACHERS,
SPECIFICALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
NEW MATH FRAMEWORK GIVEN THE
STATUS OF MATHEMATICS ACCESS AND
ACHIEVEMENT, CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED STATES HAVE NEEDED TO
DEVELOP NEW APPROACHES FOR
DEEPENING MATH LEARNING,
ADDRESSING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS, AND
MODERNIZING INSTRUCTION TO MEET
THE DEMANDS OF A FAST CHANGING
WORLD. THESE DEMANDS REQUIRE NEW
APPROACHES THAT DRAW FROM
PROVEN, EVIDENCE BASED OUTCOMES
FOR PUPILS AND RESEARCH ON ON
EFFECTIVE EDUCATOR KNOWLEDGE AND
INSTRUCTION. WE WANT TO PROVIDE
THE KIND OF PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING SUPPORT THAT IMPROVES
STUDENT ENGAGEMENT, COMBATS
INEQUITIES, AND SERVES EDUCATORS
WHERE THEY ARE APPEALING TO
THEIR VARIED RESPONSIBILITIES
AND MEETING THEM AT THEIR
CURRENT CAREER STAGES AND ROLES.
WHILE CALIFORNIA SAW LESS
PANDEMIC DECLINE THAN OTHER
STATES ON NATIONAL MATH TESTS,
WE STILL SEE I'M SORRY, WE STILL
RANK BELOW THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
ON FOURTH AND EIGHTH GRADE MATH
ASSESSMENTS IN 2022, ONLY 33% OF
STUDENTS MET OR EXCEEDED
ASSESSMENTS IN MATHEMATICS, AND
SUBSTANTIAL ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
CONTINUE TO EXIST, ESPECIALLY
FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN, AMERICAN
INDIAN AND ALASKA NATIVE AND
LATINO STUDENTS. THE PROPOSED
MATHEMATICS PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT ENTAILS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BETWEEN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, A SELECT COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION, AND THE
CALIFORNIA MATHEMATICS PROJECT.
THIS PARTNERSHIP SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THE CRITICAL NEED IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM, THE
DEVELOPMENT AND PROVISION OF
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING IN FOR
MATHEMATICS COACHES AND
EDUCATORS. SO, OVER THE LAST
YEAR OR SO, WE'VE HAD MANY
DISCUSSIONS WITH TEACHERS AND
TEACHER LEADERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS IN SCHOOLS WHERE
STUDENTS ARE THRIVING IN
MATHEMATICS CLASSROOMS. DESPITE
THE UPHEAVAL OF THE PAST SEVERAL
SEVERAL YEARS AND OUR
PERFORMANCE, OUR STUDENT
PERFORMANCE AT THIS TIME,
THEY'VE TOLD US A FEW THINGS.
THEY'VE SAID THAT WE NEED
INSTRUCTIONAL COACHES.
INSTRUCTIONAL COACHES ARE
CRITICAL FOR BUILDING TEACHER
MATH KNOWLEDGE AND IMPROVING
INSTRUCTIONAL PRACTICES. REYES
TEACHERS ON SPECIAL ASSIGNMENT
AND MATH COORDINATORS WHO ACT AS
TEACHING COACHES AND LEADERS OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT, ARE
EFFECTIVE IN MODELING LESSONS
FOR BOTH NEW AND VETERAN
TEACHERS, AS WAS HIGHLIGHTED.
THAT WE'VE SEEN THROUGH POWERFUL
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING. MULTIPLE
DISTRICTS HAVE REPORTED THAT
GETTING ADMINISTRATORS TO
UNDERSTAND THE MATH FRAMEWORK
AND WHAT THEY SHOULD BE LOOKING
FOR IN MATHEMATICS CLASSROOMS IS
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE EFFORT
TO RAISE THE QUALITY OF MATH
INSTRUCTION AND PROVIDE
CONSISTENCY ACROSS CLASSROOMS
AND SCHOOL SITES, AND THEN
BUY-IN FROM TEACHERS IS
IMPORTANT FOR EFFECTIVE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
PROVIDING A VARIETY OF CHOICE IN
WHAT KIND OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THEY NEED AND HOW
THEY RECEIVE. IT ALLOWS TEACHERS
TO ENTER PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WHERE THEY FEEL THEY
NEED THE MOST SUPPORT, AND IN
WAYS THAT WILL MOST POSITIVELY
TRANSLATE INTO IMPROVED MATH
INSTRUCTION, FUNDING FOR THE
MATHEMATICS PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT ALONG WITH
STATE BOARD. I'M SORRY, SENATE
BILL 1115 WILL EQUIP
INSTRUCTIONAL COACHES AND
EDUCATORS WITH THE TOOLS AND
TRAINING NEEDED TO ENHANCE THE
QUALITY OF MATH INSTRUCTION
DELIVERED IN OUR CLASSROOMS. I
DO WANT TO ADD THAT SB 105 GOES
FURTHER TO PROVIDE EVIDENCE
BASED PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
ACROSS A WIDER RANGE OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS, SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE'LL MOVE ON
TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. ALSO
MENTIONED IN YOUR AGENDA IS,
THERE IS PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY THAT THE
LEARNING RECOVERY BLOCK GRANT
CAN BE USED FOR MATHEMATIC
FRAMEWORK PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES. AND
GIVEN THAT WE JUST VIEW THAT THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE TO $20 MILLION
SEEMS DUPLICATIVE WITH THAT
CLARIFICATION, SO AGAIN, GIVEN
THAT OVERLAP, BUT THEN ALSO THE
STATE BUDGET CONDITION RECOMMEND
REJECTING THE $20 MILLION
PROPOSAL. WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
ONE DRAWBACK IS WE'RE RELYING ON
LOCALS TO MAKE THE DECISION ON
WHAT TYPE OF MATHEMATIC
FRAMEWORK PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TO PROVIDE, RATHER
THAN ADOPTING THIS MORE
STATEWIDE APPROACH. IF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTED TO DO A MORE
STATEWIDE APPROACH, IT COULD
JUST TRY TO IDENTIFY WHAT
EXISTING FUND SOURCES DO WE HAVE
THAT COULD ABSORB THIS
ADDITIONAL $20 MILLION COST, AND
POTENTIALLY OR FUND SOURCE THAT
MAYBE WE CAN JUST SET ASIDE A
PORTION OF DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
THIS SPECIFIC, INITIATIVE AS
OPPOSED TO PROVIDING A NEW
MONEY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THEN MY ONE QUESTION IS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, AND
IT'S OFF OF THAT. IT'S LIKE WHAT
WILL BE PROVIDED AIDED BY THE 20
MILLION THAT WOULDN'T BE
PROVIDED OTHERWISE. AND IS IT OR
IS IT NOT SORT OF DUPLICATIVE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON. HOW WOULD YOU
SPEAK TO THAT? MEGAN SABA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO THE
LEARNING RECOVERY EMERGENCY
BLOCK GRANT, THE PROVISION
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TRAILER BILL, IT IT IS AN
EXAMPLE OF VARIOUS SUPPORTS THAT
ARE ALLOWABLE USES OF THOSE
FUNDS. SO WHILE AN LEA CAN USE
THEIR EMERGENCY BLOCK GRANT
FUNDS FOR TRAINING ALIGNED WITH
THE NEW MATHEMATICS FRAMEWORK
FOR TEACHERS, THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE THAT THEY WILL. SO
CARVING OUT THIS $20 MILLION
PROPOSAL, ENSURES THAT THERE ARE
FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR LEAS OR
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
ENSURE THAT EDUCATORS GET THIS
TRAINING AND THAT THEY THEY HAVE
RESOURCES TO MEET THESE THESE
NEW THIS NEW FRAMEWORK. OKAY.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES HERE. THAT
WAS THE QUESTION I HAD. SO IT
COMES DOWN TO A QUESTION OF
PRIORITIES. SO I'M HOPING THE
PRIORITY IS THIS PROGRAM.
BECAUSE CLEARLY YOU LOOK AT THE
DATA IT'S MUCH NEEDED. I DON'T
KNOW FULLER QUESTIONS. NO.
THAT'S A HELPFUL COMMENT.
SENATOR MINH. THEN, I THINK
WE'VE JUST HAD THE DISCUSSION
THAT SETS UP YOUR DISCUSSION FOR
BETWEEN NOW AND, AND THE END OF
THE BUDGET TIME. AND OF COURSE,
IT'LL BE INFLUENCED BY THE FACT
OF WHETHER WE HAVE MONEY IN THE
UNIVERSE. AND, THAT'S WHY
ANYTHING THAT'S NEW IS REALLY
SUBJECT TO REAL QUESTIONING AS
WE MOVE AHEAD. BUT I FEEL LIKE
WE DEALT WITH THAT ISSUE. SO
THANK YOU. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. AND WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO ISSUE THREE, THE
LITERACY SCREENER PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. WE HAVE TWO RETURN.
WITNESSES. AND THEN NANCY
BRYNELSON FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WILL JOIN US. AND WE
WILL GO IN THAT ORDER, STARTING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
MEGAN SABA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
, SO I'LL GIVE YOU A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THIS PROPOSAL, THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, AS A REMINDER
, THE 2023 BUDGET ACT RATHER
REQUIRED LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES, OR LEAS TO BEGIN
SCREENING PUPILS IN KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH SECOND GRADE FOR RISK OF
READING DIFFICULTIES BY THE 20
2526 SCHOOL YEAR. THE SCREENINGS
WILL BE A TOOL THAT LEAS CAN USE
TO IDENTIFY PUPILS EXPERIENCING
DIFFICULTY READING TO SUPPORT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SCREENINGS. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF
25 MILLION. ONGOING. PROPOSITION
98 GENERAL FUND TO THE MANDATES
BLOCK GRANT, BEGINNING IN 20
2425 TO SUPPORT TRAINING FOR
EDUCATORS TO ADMINISTER THE
LITERACY SCREENINGS AS REQUIRED
BY THE 2023 BUDGET ACT. TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE PROVIDES AN
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY FOR THOSE
FUNDS, SO COMMENCING WITH THE 20
2425 FISCAL YEAR, THE LANGUAGE
PROPOSES TO ALLOCATE FUNDS TO
LEAS AT A PER PUPIL RATE USING
FALL ONE CENSUS ENROLLMENT DATA
FOR PUPILS IN KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH GRADE TWO, CONSISTENT
WITH THE REQUIREMENT IN LAW,
THIS CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW.
THANK YOU. AND THEN WELCOME,
WE'LL GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE. I'M NANCY
BRYNILDSEN, STATEWIDE LITERACY
CO-DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION,
PRESENTING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION, TONY
THURMOND. I WILL BEGIN BY
SUPPORTING THE IMPLEMENT PORTION
OF THE SCREENING FOR RISK OF
READING DIFFICULTY IS ALONG THE
TIMELINE OUTLINED IN EDUCATION
CODE 53008, WHICH WOULD MEAN
THAT THIS COMING SCHOOL YEAR, 20
2425 IS A PLANNING AND
PREPARATION YEAR. AND THEN THE
FOLLOWING YEAR WOULD BE WHEN ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD NEED TO IMPLEMENT THIS
SCREENING FOR STUDENTS IN
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH GRADE TWO.
I WILL OUTLINE SOME OF THOSE
PREPARATION STEPS THAT DISTRICTS
NEED TO TAKE SO THAT YOU SEE
THEIR IMPORTANCE AND THE FACT
THAT DISTRICTS WILL INCUR SOME
UPFRONT COSTS. THIS COMING
SCHOOL YEAR RELATED TO
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. AND
I'LL TALK A BIT MORE ABOUT WHAT
THAT WILL ENTAIL FOR THE
SELECTION OF AN INSTRUMENT OR
INSTRUMENTS FROM THE APPROVED
LIST AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF
PLANS TO IMPLEMENT THE SCREENING
. THAT WILL INCLUDE STAFFING AND
SCHEDULING AND REPORTING AND
COMMUNICATION STRATEGIES, ETC.
NOT FUNDING THESE START UP COSTS
THIS COMING YEAR WILL PUSH BACK,
IMPLEMENTATION, MOST LIKELY,
BEYOND THE BEGINNING OF THE 2526
SCHOOL YEAR AS AS DISTRICTS NEED
TO RAMP UP AND REALLY CONSIDER
HOW THEY WILL IMPLEMENT THESE
NEW REQUIREMENTS. IMPORTANTLY,
THE EFFECTIVE USE OF NEW
SCREENERS FOR RISK OF READING
DIFFICULTIES DEPENDS ON
IMPLEMENTING THEM WITHIN A
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT SYSTEM
THAT INFORMS DATA BASED DECISION
MAKING WITHIN A MULTI-TIERED
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT THAT BEGINS
WITH SCREENERS, AT THE UNIVERSAL
LEVEL OF INSTRUCTION FOR EARLY
IDENTIFICATION, AND TO DETERMINE
IF, IF ANY ADDITIONAL ASSESSMENT
OR INTERVENTIONS ARE NEEDED.
HOWEVER, SCREENERS ALONE ARE NOT
SUFFICIENT. A COMPREHENSIVE
SYSTEM ALSO INCLUDES DIAGNOSTIC
ASSESSMENTS SHOULD FURTHER
ASSESSMENT BE INDICATED BY THE
SCREENING? PERIODIC BENCHMARK
ASSESSMENTS TO DETERMINE STUDENT
PROGRESS AND RESPONSE TO
INSTRUCTION AND ONGOING
CLASSROOM FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT
PROCESSES. IN ADDITION, ALL OF
THIS MUST BE ACCOMPANIED BY HIGH
QUALITY CURRICULAR AND
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES,
INCLUDING INTERVENTIONS FOR
STUDENTS WHO NEED THEM. SO WHAT
SPECIFICALLY DO DISTRICTS NEED
TO DO SO STARTING IN THE FALL?
YES. WE WON'T HAVE A LIST IN
SEPTEMBER, LEAS NEED TO ANALYZE
THEIR OWN SYSTEMS OF ASSESSMENT,
CURRICULUM, INSTRUCTION AND
INTERVENTION TO CREATE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO
IMPLEMENT THIS IN THE EVENT THAT
THEY AREN'T ALREADY DOING IT. OR
PERHAPS THEY ARE. FURTHERMORE
THEY NEED TO DETERMINE THE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NECESSARY
TO BUILD KNOWLEDGE OF READING
DIFFICULTIES, INCLUDING DYSLEXIA
. LEAS CAN LOOK TO WHAT THE
PANEL IS DOING NOW. THE READING
DIFFICULTIES RISK SCREENER
SELECTION PANEL THAT WAS
APPOINTED BY THE STATE BOARD IN
JANUARY, AND THEY'RE DEVELOPING
CRITERIA FOR THE EVALUATION OF
THOSE INSTRUMENTS. THESE AND SO
DISTRICTS COULD BE LOOKING TO
PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
FOR THEIR EDUCATORS IN ALL OF
THE DOMAINS ENUMERATED IN THE
EDUCATION CODE. EDUCATORS ALSO
NEED TO LEARN ABOUT SCREENING
AND ASSESSMENT CONSIDERATIONS
FOR MULTILINGUAL AND CULTURALLY
DIVERSE STUDENTS AND APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTIONS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. AND THEY NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT EVIDENCE BASED
CLASSROOM INTERVENTIONS FOR ANY
STUDENT WHO IS IDENTIFIED AS
HAVING A RISK FOR READING
DIFFICULTY. SO THAT'S THE FALL
WE'RE RAMPING UP. WE'RE PLANNING
THEN IN THE WINTER AND SPRING
AFTER THE LIST IS ESTABLISHED,
THE DISTRICT NEEDS TO TURN ITS
ATTENTION TO ACTUALLY REVIEWING
THE INSTRUMENTS THAT ARE
APPROVED, PERHAPS PILOTING THEM.
THAT WOULD BE A BEST PRACTICE
INVOLVING THEIR FACULTY Kò ALL
THEIR EDUCATORS, COMPETENCY
RATING TEACHERS FOR THEIR STAFF,
TIME TO REVIEW THESE INSTRUMENTS
. AND, SELECTING THE INSTRUMENTS
THAT ARE MOST APPROPRIATE FOR
THE STUDENT POPULATIONS. SO
KEEPING THE INTENT OF THE
SCREENERS TO ENSURE EARLY
IDENTIFICATION OF STUDENTS WHO
NEED ADDITIONAL READING SUPPORT
AND NOT THE DIAGNOSIS OF
DISABILITIES. SO THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT POINT, IS THAT THIS IS
DOES NOT AUTOMATICALLY QUALIFY A
CHILD FOR ANY PARTICULAR
SERVICE, BUT IT DOES INDICATE
EITHER RISK OR POSSIBLE
EXISTENCE OF A DISABILITY. AND
THEN THE NEED TO DO FURTHER WORK
, THE OTHER PROVISION THAT'S
PROBABLY IMPORTANT TO NOTE HERE
IS THAT, IN THE CODE, IT
ENCOURAGES THE IDENTIFICATION OF
INSTRUMENTS IN THE HOME
LANGUAGES OF STUDENTS, SHOULD
THOSE BE AVAILABLE AND MEET THE
CRITERIA. THERE ARE PROVISIONS
FOR ADDITIONAL OR ALTERNATE
METHODS OF DETERMINING, STUDENTS
RISK OF READING DIFFICULTIES
THAT WOULD BE CONDUCTED BY THE
LÀ SHOULD AN INSTRUMENT NOT BE
AVAILABLE. AND SO DISTRICTS ARE
GOING TO NEED TO PLAN FOR THAT.
PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
STAFF FOR THAT, ETC. SO ALL IN
ALL, THERE IS WORK TO BE DONE
AND IT NEEDS TO BE DONE
THOUGHTFULLY WITHIN A
COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM. AND WE
RECOMMEND THAT WE STAY ON TRACK
AND THAT WE SUPPORT DISTRICTS
WITH THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
DO THE JOB. THANK YOU. I'M SURE
WE'LL HAVE SOME QUESTIONS, LET'S
MOVE TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST.
AS NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA IN OUR
REVIEW OF THE PROPOSAL, OVERALL,
WE RECOMMEND DELAYING THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF THE
SCREENER REQUIRED MOMENT,
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE AS IT
RELATES TO THE TRAINING FUNDS,
THE $25 MILLION IS NOT
NECESSARILY TIED TO ANYTHING IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE, ONE, THE
SCREENER TOOLS HAVE YET TO BE
DEVELOPED THE LIST OF POSSIBLE
SCREENING TOOLS AND LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES HAVE YET TO
SELECT WHICH SCREENING TOOLS
THEY WOULD USE. AND THEN THE
NUMBER OF EDUCATORS THAT WOULD
NEED TO BE TRAINED TO ADMINISTER
THESE TOOLS. SO IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO ASSESS THE ACCURACY
OF COST AT THIS POINT IN TIME,
SECONDLY, THE FUNDING MECHANISM
GOING THROUGH THE MANDATES BLOCK
GRANT, TRADITIONALLY, WE PROVIDE
FUNDS AFTER THE ACTIVITY HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED AND WE HAVE A
SENSE OF ACTUAL COST. SO WE'RE
PROPOSING DOLLARS THROUGH THE
MANDATE BLOCK GRANT EARLIER THAN
TRADITIONAL PRACTICES, SO
OVERALL WE RECOMMEND AGAIN
DELAYING THE OVERALL
IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF THE
SCREENER TOOLS BECAUSE THIS
WOULD ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROPERLY ASSESS ONGOING COSTS,
NOT JUST TRAINING COSTS, BUT ANY
OTHER ASSOCIATED ASSESSMENT
COSTS THAT WOULD RESULT FROM THE
SCREENERS, IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW
THE LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE
WHAT MECHANISM TO FUND THESE
ACTIVITIES SHOULD WE GO THROUGH
THE BLOCK GRANT OR MAKE AN
ANNUAL BUDGET APPROPRIATION THAT
THE LEGISLATURE COULD MONITOR
AND HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
ADJUST ON AN ONGOING BASIS, BUT
THEN ALSO, AGAIN, IT WOULD AVOID
ADDING AN ADDITIONAL ONGOING
COST AT THIS TIME WHEN WE'RE
FORECASTING THAT 98, CANNOT
SUPPORT EVEN EXISTING
COMMITMENTS. THANK YOU. OKAY.
THANK YOU. LET ME START BY
ASKING MY COLLEAGUES IF THERE'S
QUESTIONS. SENATOR, I GUESS
WITHOUT I DON'T MEAN TO SOUND
FLIP, I LIKE IS IT HARD TO TELL
IF PEOPLE HAVE LITERACY ISSUES
AND WHAT ARE THE EXISTING TOOLS?
ARE THERE? DO ANY OF OUR LEAS
ALREADY HAVE TOOLS IN PLACE? AND
I GUESS THAT WOULD BE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. MANY
LEAS HAVE PURCHASE BASED
SCREENING INSTRUMENTS TO USE.
THE INTENT OF A SCREENING
INSTRUMENT IS TO BE BRIEF AND TO
ASSESS A WHOLE RANGE OF ISSUES
FROM PHONOLOGICAL AWARENESS,
ALPHABET KNOWLEDGE, THE THERE
ARE ABOUT TEN SPECIFIC THINGS I
COULD NAME. AND SO THESE
INSTRUMENTS NEED TO BE CAREFULLY
DESIGNED TO BE BRIEF,
APPROPRIATE FOR THE AGE OF THESE
STUDENTS AND TO YIELD VALID AND
RELIABLE RESULTS. SO, I MEAN,
TEACHERS ALWAYS HAVE A SENSE,
BUT THE PURPOSE OF UNIVERSAL
SCREENING IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
NO CHILD FALLS BETWEEN THE
CRACKS AND THE ADVOCATES FOR
THIS WOULD SAY THAT TOO MANY
CHILDREN HAVE IN THE PAST AND
SHOW UP LATER IN THIRD GRADE AND
FOURTH GRADE, AS HAVING
SIGNIFICANT DIFFICULTIES IN
PERHAPS EVEN QUALIFYING FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T GET THE TYPE OF SUPPORT
EARLIER ON THAT WOULD HAVE
AVOIDED THAT. I APPRECIATE THE
ANSWER TO THAT. I GUESS I FOLLOW
UP AND ASK HOW, I MEAN, HOW
WOULD YOU RESPOND TO THE LAWS
POINT, WHICH I THINK IS A FAIR
ONE, AND WE'RE IN A VERY BUDGET
CONSTRAINED ENVIRONMENT. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW, PULLING
BACK ON A LOT OF DIFFERENT
SOURCES OF FUNDING. THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT WILL HAVE AN
ONGOING COST, THAT MANY LEAS MAY
ALREADY BE DOING TO SOME DEGREE.
I MEAN, I GUESS, CAN YOU MAKE
THE CASE TO US THAT, THAT THIS
IS LOOK, I THINK WE ALL THINK
LITERACY IS CRUCIAL AND LITERACY
SCREENING SEEMS LIKE A VALUABLE
TOOL, BUT IT'S A TOOL THAT WILL
REQUIRE TRAINING, PURCHASING THE
TOOLS. AND I KNOW THAT MANY OF
OUR TEACHERS ARE ALREADY
OVERWORKED AS IT IS. THEY HAVE A
NUMBER OF RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
ADDRESS LITERACY. SO I GUESS,
YOU KNOW, WHAT'S THE CASE WE
SHOULD MAKE FOR FUNDING THIS
PROGRAM NOW, AS OPPOSED TO MAYBE
IN THE FUTURE WHEN, WHEN PERHAPS
WE HAVE MORE MONEY. THE
ADVANTAGE OF ASSESSING STUDENTS
EARLY ON IN THE SCHOOL YEAR, AND
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE 25, 26
SCHOOL YEAR, IS THAT WE CAN PLAN
INSTRUCTION APPROPRIATELY FOR
THE REMAINDER OF THE YEAR OR
IDENTIFY CHILDREN WHO NEED
FURTHER ASSESSMENT. THAT MEANS
IF YOU WE DO SOME BACKWARDS
MAPPING HERE, WE NEED TO
IDENTIFY BY THE INSTRUMENTS. WE
NEED TO DO SPECIFIC PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR THOSE
INSTRUMENTS, CREATE SCHEDULES
AND PERHAPS EVEN HIRE THE STAFF
TO DO THAT, THAT'S GOING TO BE A
BIG QUESTION. CLASSROOM TEACHERS
MAY BE THE ONES DOING THESE
ASSESSMENTS, BUT THEY MAY NEED
TO BE SUPPORTED BY ADDITIONAL
STAFF SO THAT THEY HAVE THE TIME
TO DO SO. THE RIPE TIME FOR
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING IS SPRING
AND SUMMER, SO THAT YOU CAN
IMPLEMENT IN THE FALL. THAT'S
THE CYCLE THAT ALMOST EVERY
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS ON. AND SO
FOR A SHIFT LEGISLATIVE CYCLE,
AS WELL, FOR A SHIFT THIS
MASSIVE, WE CAN'T WAIT TILL
SCHOOL OPENS IN AUGUST AND THEN
SAY, OH, BY THE WAY, YOU KNOW,
IN TWO WEEKS YOU'LL NEED TO DO
THIS. AND WE NEED TO GIVE YOU A
SCHEDULE, TELL YOU HOW TO TALK
TO YOUR PARENTS, ETC, ETC. SO WE
JUST FEEL STRONGLY THAT ALL THE
PLANNING NEEDS TO OCCUR SO THAT
PURCHASING HAPPENS IN THE SPRING
OF 25 AND PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
BEGINS, AND ALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR INTERVENTION
IS ESTABLISHED. THEN LET ME ASK
A FOLLOW UP QUESTION, BECAUSE
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY HIGH LEVEL
DISCUSSION ABOUT BUDGET AND
PROCESS, AND I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IF I'M A KID THAT'S
STRUGGLING WITH LEARNING, HOW DO
I SEE THIS? HOW DO I SEE MY
NEEDS ADDRESSED? HOW DOES IT
COME OUT OF THE END OF ALL THIS?
ARE SO WHAT IS IT WE'RE GOING TO
DO AS A RESULT? NO, I DO IT FROM
THE VANTAGE POINT OF A STUDENT.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ALL THE
THINGS UP TO THE STUDENT. YES. I
WANT TO KNOW, HOW DOES A STUDENT
SEE THIS AND HOW DOES A STUDENT
BENEFIT A STUDENT BENEFITS
BECAUSE THEY ARE SUPPORTED TO
STAY ON TRACK WITH THE SKILLS
THEY NEED TO LEARN TO BE
PROFICIENT IN LITERACY, STUDENTS
WHO BECOME FURTHER AND FURTHER
BEHIND IN THE PRIMARY GRADES
EXPERIENCED TRAUMA THEIR
PARENTS. LET ME ASK YOU A
DIFFERENT WAY. I'M A STUDENT
THAT'S BEHIND IN THE EARLIER
GRADES. HOW DOES THIS REACH ME?
WHEN DOES THIS ACTUALLY GET TO
ME? HOW DO I EXPERIENCE? THERE'S
A DIFFERENCE IN MY EXPERIENCE
BECAUSE OF THIS PROGRAM. IT GETS
TO YOU ALMOST IMMEDIATELY
BECAUSE IF WE'RE USING THE
MULTI-TIERED SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
AND THE CONTINUUM OF SUPPORT, WE
HAVE UNIVERSAL SUPPORT
INSTRUCTION FOR ALL STUDENTS. WE
HAVE SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS WHO HAVE SPECIFIC NEEDS
THAT CAN BE IN CLASS. IT CAN BE
SUPPORTED BY PARAPROFESSIONALS,
BY READING LANGUAGE ARTS
SPECIALISTS, AND THEN FOR
STUDENTS WITH MORE INTENSIVE
NEEDS, WE HAVE INTENSIFIED
SUPPORT, RIGHT AWAY. AND SO THUS
BEGINS A PROCESS IN KINDERGARTEN
AND FIRST GRADE. I WAS A FORMER
SCHOOL PRINCIPAL. WE USED TO BE
TOLD, YOU GOT TO WAIT TILL
THERE'S A GAP IN BETWEEN. THERE
POTENTIAL AND THEIR PERFORMANCE.
AND WE WAITED TILL THIRD AND
FOURTH GRADE. THOSE KIDS DIDN'T
CATCH UP. OKAY, WE NEED TO
DESIGN THAT SYSTEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT CONTINUUM OF SUPPORT IS
REALLY IMPLEMENTED. SO THIS IS A
BIGGER ISSUE THAN JUST THE
SCREENER. THIS IS REALLY MAKING
SURE THAT LEAS UNDERSTAND HOW TO
CREATE THIS. NOW WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
IT'S IN OUR FRAMEWORK. IT'S IN
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING THAT WE
ALREADY DO. BUT AS THE STUDENT,
THEY SHOULD START TO SEE
CHANGES. THEY MAY NEED MORE
INSTRUCTION IN IN A PARTICULAR
SKILL. AND THEY MAY NEED
INTENSIFIED INSTRUCTION IN THIS
SKILL. SO THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
PAIN POINT REALLY DOES GET TO
THEM. IT HAS TO GET TO THEM. I
KNOW IT HAS TO. I'M ASKING IF IT
DOES, BECAUSE THAT'S THE THING
THAT WORRIES ME, THAT WE HAVE A
PERFECT PROCESS, THAT IT NEVER
QUITE GETS TO THEM. IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON THE LÀ PUTTING INTO
PLACE. THE PLANS FOR THAT
CONTINUUM OF SUPPORT, AND MAKING
SURE THAT ALL TEACHERS ARE HAVE
HIGH QUALITY PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING AND THAT THEY HAVE THE
INSTRUCTION MATERIALS NEEDED TO
IMPLEMENT SUCH A PROGRAM, THIS
NEEDS TO BE CAREFULLY PLANNED,
CAREFULLY CONSTRUCTED, CAREFULLY
MONITORED STEP BY STEP, SO THAT
INDEED JUST WHAT YOU'RE SAYING,
AS LONG AS THERE'S A LOT MORE
MONEY AND A LOT MORE EFFORT AND
A BUDGET CONSTRAINT CONSTRAINT
THING, THIS WILL WORK. I WOULD
SAY THAT THIS HAS ALL THE
POTENTIAL TO WORK IF WE PAY
ATTENTION TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF UNIVERSAL SCREENING AND ALL
OF THE ATTENDANT, FINANCE
DOESN'T USUALLY WANT TO TALK,
BUT THEY HAVE ASKED TO TALK. SO
MEGAN SABA, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I JUST WANTED TO KIND OF
QUICKLY COLOR SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT IS MAKING. WITH
MORE OF A FISCAL PERSPECTIVE. SO
THE CURRENT REQUIREMENT IN LAW
REQUIRES THAT LEAS BEGIN
SCREENING PUPILS IN THE 2526
SCHOOL YEAR IN THAT KINDERGARTEN
TO SECOND GRADE GRADE SPAN. WE
HAVE DATA, AND I'LL LEAVE IT TO
MY COLLEAGUE TO COLOR THAT DATA
FURTHER, THAT STUDENTS ARE
FALLING BEHIND IN READING AND
LITERACY RIGHT NOW. SO IF WE
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
REQUIREMENT, WE DELAY
IDENTIFICATION OF READING
DIFFICULTIES AND READING
DISABILITIES. AND STUDENTS, AND
I WANT TO NOTE HERE TOO, THAT
PARENTS ARE ALSO BROUGHT INTO
THIS CONVERSATION WHEN THEY,
THEY, THEY GET THE RESULTS OF
THE OF THE READING SCREENING. SO
THIS MAKES PARENTS AWARE THAT
THERE MAY BE READING OR LITERACY
DIFFICULTY GOING ON WITH THEIR,
THEIR CHILD. SO, SO DELAYING
DELAYING THIS WOULD DELAY
IDENTIFICATION. SO I CAN'T
REALLY SPEAK TO, TO FURTHER
SCREENING. BUT I CAN I CAN SPEAK
TO THE IDENTIFICATION COMPONENT,
WHICH EVERY CHILD WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO IN CALIFORNIA UNDER
UNDER THE CURRENT PROPOSAL, AND
THEN TO SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE
TO COSTS, I WANT TO QUICKLY
RECOGNIZE, SAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THAT,
UPFRONT COSTS OF IMPLEMENTATION
WILL LIKELY BE HIGHER, AND SO
THIS LANGUAGE OF PROVIDING THE
$25 MILLION CARVED OUT UP FRONT
IS, AVOIDS DILUTION OF THE FUNDS
AND ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THE SHAPE
OF THESE FUNDS MAY LIKELY CHANGE
OVER TIME AS WE START TO SEE
MANDATE TEST CLAIMS COME THROUGH
THE PROCESS, AND WE WOULD LIKELY
SEE THOSE COSTS COME DOWN IN THE
OUT YEARS. WHY? WHY WOULD THEY
COME DOWN IN THE OUT YEARS? THEY
WOULD COME DOWN AND SORRY THEY
WOULD COME DOWN IN THE OUT YEARS
BECAUSE THE UPFRONT COSTS OF
IMPLEMENTATION, TRAINING,
ADOPTING SCREENING TOOLS FOR
LEAS, IT'S MORE COSTLY, ONCE
THEY HAVE THE COSTS OF
DISPROPORTIONATELY FRONTLOADED.
CORRECT. OKAY. AND THEN I HAD
ANOTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTION I'VE
NOTICED IN WHAT'S SAID. IT'S
THAT EVERY STUDENT AND EVERY
STUDENT HAS BEEN MENTIONED, BUT
HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE THAT
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND KIDS THAT
MIGHT BE MULTILINGUAL IN
DIFFERENT WAYS ARE NOT ARE
CAUGHT IN THIS AND THAT THEIR
ISSUES ARE ACTUALLY ADDRESSED?
SO MY FELLOW PANELISTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THIS. THE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL REQUIRES THAT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE SCREENING INSTRUMENTS
ADOPTED BY THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. CURRENT STATUTE
REQUIRES THAT THOSE SCREENING
INSTRUMENTS, PROVIDE ASSESSMENTS
FOR BOTH ENGLISH SPEAKING AND
NON-ENGLISH SPEAKING PUPILS IN
LANGUAGES REFLECTING THE PRIMARY
LANGUAGES OF THE PUPILS IN THE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY IN
WHICH THAT TOOL IS ADMINISTERED
TO THE EXTENT THAT ASSESSMENTS
IN THOSE LANGUAGES ARE AVAILABLE
. OKAY, AND BEFORE WE START TO
WRAP UP, THIS HAS BEEN A DIALOG
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND FINANCE SINCE YOU
TALKED. IS THERE ANYTHING YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ADD AFTER HEARING
THIS? I THINK A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT WE WOULD FLAG IS ONE, ON
THE UNDERSTANDING OF UPFRONT
COSTS MAY BE HIGHER. HOWEVER, I
WOULD JUST REITERATE OUR POINT
THAT WE DON'T EVEN HAVE THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION TO ASSESS
WHETHER THE 25 MILLION IS AN
ACCURATE ASSESSMENT OF THOSE
HIGHER UPFRONT COSTS, BECAUSE,
AGAIN, WE DON'T KNOW THE TYPE OF
SCREENER TOOLS THAT WILL BE
ADOPTED, HOW LEAS WILL PROPOSE
TO USE THOSE SCREENER TOOLS AND
THE NECESSARY TRAINING
ACTIVITIES THAT, WOULD WHAT
WOULD COME AFTER THAT? I THINK
IT'S ALSO THE FACT THAT THIS IS
GOING THROUGH THE MANDATES BLOCK
GRANT. I THINK WE WOULD JUST
FLAG TRADITIONALLY, ONCE A COST
IS BUILT INTO THE MANDATE BLOCK
GRANT, IT IS FIXED IN TIME. SO
THIS IS ALSO A NEW APPROACH IN
COSTING THINGS OUT THROUGH A
MANDATES BLOCK GRANT, WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SAYING IT IS
MOVABLE. IT IS IT IS A COST THAT
WE CAN ADJUST MOVING FORWARD,
WHICH I THINK FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE. WHY NOT THEN JUST
GO THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS, IF IT'S A MOVING TARGET
AS OPPOSED TO MAKING IT INTO A
FUNDING MECHANISM THAT'S
TYPICALLY FIXED, I THINK THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
ANXIOUS TO TALK AGAIN. MEGAN
SABA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I DO
JUST WANT TO QUICKLY NOTE THAT
WHILE WE ARE, THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES PROPOSE RAMOS TO
BUILD THIS $25 MILLION IN THE
MANDATES BLOCK GRANT, IT
WOULDN'T GO OUT TO LEAS THE WAY
THAT MANDATES TYPICALLY DO,
BECAUSE WE DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE
TEST CLAIMS. FUNNELING THIS
FUNDING THROUGH THE MANDATES
BLOCK GRANT IS AN ACKNOWLEDGMENT
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE WILL
WE WILL SEE MANDATE TEST CLAIMS
FOR THIS REQUIREMENT, ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT AND I'M HAPPY TO GO
OVER IT AGAIN TO THAT THERE IS A
SEPARATE ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY
FOR THESE FUNDS, DIFFERENT FROM
THE RATES METHODOLOGY PROVIDED
IN THE MANDATES BLOCK GRANT FOR
OTHER MANDATE COSTS. SENATOR
WILK HAS BEEN PATIENTLY WAITING,
BUT JUST BEFORE I GET TO HIM,
LET ME ASK A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME THERE'S
THIS WEIRD BALANCE HERE WHERE
NORMALLY FINANCE IS PINCHING
EVERY PENNY UNTIL YOU HAVE TO DO
IT, AND HERE THEY'RE
RECOMMENDING NOT WAITING FOR THE
AFTER THE FACT MANDATE AND
SPENDING THE MONEY UP FRONT. AND
AT THE SAME TIME, DOING IT
OUTSIDE OF THE MANDATE PROCESS
DOESN'T LOCK IT IN GOING FORWARD
AND ALLOWS FOR THE KIND OF
DIFFERENCE THAT WAS JUST MADE.
AND SO I'M NOT SURE WE'RE GOING
TO RESOLVE IT HERE, BUT I WOULD
JUST CALL ATTENTION AS WE HAVE
DISCUSSIONS GOING TO MAY 15TH
AND JUNE 15TH, THAT THOSE ARE
THE ISSUES AT PLAY. AND IF WE'RE
SITTING HERE STRAPPED FOR MONEY,
IT SEEMS KIND OF DIFFICULT TO
IMAGINE DOING IT UP FRONT WHEN
WE DON'T HAVE TO DO IT UP FRONT.
SO JUST, YOU KNOW, TO MAKE THAT
STATEMENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE, SENATOR WILK, AND
LETTING ME FOLLOW UP WITH THAT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. SO MANY OF
US WHO SIT IN THE LEGISLATURE
COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT, AND
A LOT OF TIMES THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. YOU GET TO SEE YOU
ACTUALLY GET TO SEE THE FRUITS
OF YOUR LABOR. WHEREAS HERE MANY
TIMES WE DON'T. AND SO I WAS
VERY EXCITED ABOUT YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY BECAUSE I WAS
PRINCIPAL COAUTHOR OF SB 691 BY
PORTANTINO. AND WE ACTUALLY HAD
LEARNED ABOUT THIS AT AN
EDUCATIONAL CONFERENCE WE WERE
AT QUITE A FEW YEARS AGO, AND WE
WERE EMBARRASSED. ONE THAT WE
DIDN'T KNOW. AND WE WERE FURTHER
EMBARRASSED THAT WE WEREN'T
DOING THIS BECAUSE THIS IS JUST
SO IMPORTANT, YOU KNOW, OUR PRO
TEM TODAY ON THE SENATE FLOOR IS
TALKING ABOUT THE BUDGET AND THE
BUDGETS THAT VALUES DOCUMENT.
WELL, THIS SHOULD BE PART OF OUR
VALUES. WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO EVERY CHILD WHICH
WE'VE BEEN FAILING, AS YOU SAID,
THE CHILDREN THAT HAS FALLEN
THROUGH THE CRACKS AND LONG
TERME, THERE'S GOING TO BE AN
ECONOMIC BENEFIT, RIGHT, BECAUSE
IF YOU ARE NOT LITERATE BY THIRD
GRADE, THAT'S THE PIPELINE TO
PRISON. SO WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO LIFT PEOPLE
UP, BE MORE PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS
OF SOCIETY. AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I KNOW WE'RE
PINCHING PENNIES, BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD. AND WE NEED TO GO FULL
STEAM ON. AND, WE DIDN'T EVEN
GET THIS THROUGH THE FIRST TIME.
IN FACT, WE HAD A MORE AMBITIOUS
PROPOSAL INITIALLY DOING
DIAGNOSTICS. SO NOW IT'S
SCREENING, WHICH I THINK I'M
CONVINCED IS ADEQUATE ENOUGH FOR
NOW. AND I KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S
VERY INTERESTED IN THIS AND HAS
TAKEN A PERSONAL INTEREST IN IT.
AND I HOPE THAT WE HELP HIM
FULFILL HIS VISION ON THIS
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY, REALLY
IMPORTANT. SO I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. ANY LAST CALL
HERE FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS THEN
I THINK WE'VE HAD A GOOD AIRING
OF THIS. AND THERE'S SOME
QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
DRILLED DOWN ON BEFORE WE GET TO
, TO THE END OF THE BUDGET. AND
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
AND, AND HELPING US WITH THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR, INCLUSIVE COLLEGE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER, THE
PANEL INCLUDES JODI LIEBERMAN
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
Ã SHILO BESSER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND
SARAH CORTEZ FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. SO
WELCOME. AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, JODI LIEBERMAN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I WILL BE
GOING OVER THE INVESTMENT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR
INCLUSIVE COLLEGE, INCLUDED IN
THE 2024 BUDGET. THE BUDGET
INCLUDES 2 MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND TO
ESTABLISH A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTER. THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTER WILL BE HOUSED IN A
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
SHALL WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THEIR LOCAL REGIONAL CENTER,
THEIR LOCAL PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION AND THE UC DAVIS
MIND INSTITUTE. THE CENTER HAS
MULTIPLE RESPONSIBILITIES
ALIGNED WITH ITS PURPOSE, WHICH
IS TO INCREASE AWARENESS AND
ACCESS TO INCLUSIVE AND
EXPERIENTIAL POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH DEGREE
CERTIFICATE OR NON-DEGREE
PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES, AND
TO ESTABLISH STATEWIDE SUPPORT
AND COORDINATION OF THE
DISSEMINATION OF INFORMATION OF
PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. FINALLY, THE
CENTER WILL SUBMIT A REPORT
ANNUALLY TO THE GOVERNOR OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE REGARDING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS SECTION.
RELEVANT DATA AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO EXPAND
EVOLVING BEST PRACTICES. THAT'S
ALL, AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL
MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING, MISS.
IT'S NOT OKAY. I'M SORRY. I WAS
TOLD RED WAS. IT WAS OFF. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS SHILO
DUNCAN. I AM THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF SPECIAL EDUCATION AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY
THURMOND. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY,
AND I'M HERE TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL. GREAT. THEN WE'LL
MOVE TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. GOOD MORNING,
SARAH CORTEZ LAO, WE DON'T HAVE
ANY SPECIFIC ANALYTICAL COMMENTS
ON THIS PROPOSAL, BUT I DO WANT
TO POINT US TO OUR OVERARCHING
COMMENTS THAT WE MADE AT A
PREVIOUS BUDGET HEARING TO GIVEN
THE BUDGET CONDITION REJECTING
RECOMMEND REJECTING ANY NEW
DISCRETION PROPOSALS. AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
? SENATOR WILK, DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTION OR COMMENT? GREAT THEN,
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT
WAS ACTUALLY TOTALLY
SELF-EXPLANATORY IN THE AGENDA.
AND I THINK THE QUESTION IS JUST
GETS DOWN TO, THE NUTS AND BOLTS
OF WHETHER WE HAVE THE MONEY
WHEN WE GET TO IT. AND SO, I'M
SORRY, THIS IS THIS WILL BE THE
BRIEFEST ITEM WE EVER HAVE, BUT
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS, AND
WE WILL LOOK AT THAT, WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE, WHICH I'M CONFIDENT WILL
NOT BE AS BRIEF, THE ELEMENTARY
ARTS CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
CREDENTIAL. AND WE HAVE A
RETURNING PANELIST, MEGAN SABA
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
AARON SCOBLE FROM THE COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING AND A
RETURN PANELIST FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. SO
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. MEGAN CHABOT,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DIRECTS THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING TO CREATE A NEW
ELEMENTARY ARTS AND MUSIC
AUTHORIZATION FOR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION, OR CTE
TEACHERS FOR ADDITIONAL PATHWAYS
FOR EXPERIENCED ARTISTS TO
PROVIDE ARTS INSTRUCTION IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL CLASSROOMS. IN
ADDITION TO PROVIDING CTE
INSTRUCTION IN GRADES SEVEN
THROUGH 12, PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL WOULD ALLOW A TEACHER WITH
A CLEAR CTE CREDENTIAL IN ARTS,
MUSIC, AND ENTERTAINMENT TO
TEACH ELEMENTARY ARTS AND MUSIC
CLASSES WITH 24 CREDITS OF
COURSEWORK, COURSEWORK
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATION
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT TEACHING
ELEMENTARY AGE STUDENTS IS
DIFFERENT FROM HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS, SO THE LANGUAGE IS
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE SOME ADDITIONAL EDUCATION AND
MENTORSHIP FOR THOSE TEACHERS.
ADDITIONALLY, THE LANGUAGE
INCLUDES PROVISIONS FOR
EMERGENCY AUTHORIZATION FOR
THOSE SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
DIFFICULTY HIRING ARTS AND MUSIC
INSTRUCTORS TO EMPLOY TEACHERS
WORKING TOWARDS THE
AUTHORIZATION THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, WE
WILL MOVE TO THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. WELCOME
TO. GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU.
AARON SKUBAL. I'M THE
CERTIFICATION DIRECTOR AT THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK OKAY.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST JACKIE
BAROCIO LAO, AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA AND OUR ANALYSIS, WE JUST
FLAGGED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERED THE BENEFITS AND
TRADE OFFS OF THIS PROPOSAL. IT
SEEMS LIKE THE INTENT BEHIND IT
IS TO ASSIST, IN, INCREASING THE
SUPPLY OF ARTS AND TEACHER
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHERS,
ESPECIALLY IN THE CONTEXT WITH,
PROPOSITION 28. HOWEVER, THERE
ARE CONCERNS OF WHETHER THIS
WILL THIS ADDITIONAL PATHWAY
WILL EFFECTIVELY PREPARE
INDIVIDUALS TO TEACH IN
ELEMENTARY AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
SETTING RELATIVE TO THE EXISTING
CREDENTIALING PATHWAY FOR THAT,
SPECIFIC FIELD. THANK YOU, LET
ME ASK A FEW QUESTIONS HERE. AND
ONE IS JUST VERY BASIC. WHEN THE
BILLION DOLLARS WAS PASSED BY
THE VOTERS, TO ALLOW MORE, ARTS
AND MUSIC IN THE SCHOOLS, IS IT
FUNDING ELIGIBLE TO DO TRAINING
FOR TEACHERS TO THAT MONEY? DO
YOU WANT TO GO FOR IT? NO GO FOR
IT. OKAY. I WAS JUST GOING TO
SAY I WOULD DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES THAT, GO OVER. YOU
MEAN THE COLLEAGUE THAT JUST
DEFERRED TO YOU? OH, NO. NO,
OKAY. I BELIEVE AMBER ALEXANDER
IS IN THE. YES. A WHOLE OTHER
COLLEAGUE IN THE ROOM WITH US.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AMBER
ALEXANDER WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I BELIEVE THE QUESTION
WAS IF THE FUNDING COULD BE USED
FOR THINGS LIKE TEACHER TRAINING
, EMPLOYMENT. THOSE. YES,
BECAUSE THE ITEM IN FRONT OF US
IS THAT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
TEACHERS TO TEACH IT. SO IF YES,
WE WANT TO TRAIN TEACHERS SO WE
HAVE ENOUGH TEACHERS. IS THAT
FUNDING ELIGIBLE? YES. I'M HAPPY
TO SPEAK TO THAT. SO THE
PROPOSITION WAS INTENDED TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR ARTS
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. SO THAT IS,
BROADLY DEFINED TO INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE VISUAL MEDIA ARTS,
KIND OF MORE YOUR TRADITIONAL
ARTS MUSIC, A WIDE VARIETY.
THERE IS A REQUIREMENT IN THE
PROPOSITION THAT IF AN LÀ HAS AN
ENROLLMENT OF 500 STUDENTS OR
GREATER, THAT AT LEAST 80% OF
THEIR FUNDING ALLOCATION BE USED
FOR EMPLOYING OF CERTIFICATED
AND CLASSIFIED STAFF TO TEACH
THOSE ARTS EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
SO ALONG WITH THAT WOULD COME
THEIR TRAINING TO BE ABLE TO DO
SO, AS, AS WELL AS, YOU KNOW,
SALARIES, THOSE TYPES OF
EXPENDITURES. THANK YOU. BECAUSE
BECAUSE THAT'S CLEARLY A NEED
GIVEN WHAT THE STAFF REPORT IS
HERE. AND THEN, WE HAVE A
LETTER. WE HAVE TWO LETTERS, BUT
BUT ONE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MUSIC EDUCATION ASSOCIATION THAT
REALLY TAKES ISSUE WITH USING
THE, THE TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PART OF THIS AS A PATHWAY TO, TO
CREDENTIAL THING. AND LET ME
ASK, MAYBE THE COMMISSION IF YOU
WOULD RESPOND TO WHAT THEIR
CONCERNS WERE. I DON'T KNOW.
HAVE YOU SEEN THE LETTER, THANK
YOU. I HAVE NOT SEEN THE LETTER,
SO I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO THAT, BUT THE, THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE AUTHORIZED
CURRENTLY TO TEACH ARTS IN AN
ELEMENTARY SETTING, WOULD BE
DEPENDENT ON THEIR DELIVERY
METHOD FOR THAT INSTRUCTION. SO
IF IT IS A SELF-CONTAINED AND
DELIVERY METHOD WHERE THAT ART
INSTRUCTION IS BEING DONE WITH
ALL OTHER SUBJECTS BEING TAUGHT,
THAT WOULD CURRENTLY BE
AUTHORIZED BY A MULTIPLE SUBJECT
TÍNH LET ME. THEY WERE GENEROUS
ENOUGH IN THEIR SEVEN PARAGRAPHS
TO PUT IN BOLD THE FIRST
SENTENCE THAT SORT OF SAYS WHAT
EACH PARAGRAPH IS ABOUT, BUT
THEY SAY THAT THE, THE, CTE, THE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION, THE
CTE INSTRUCTION AND ARTS, MEDIA
AND ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
SECTORS DO NOT EXIST FOR
TEACHING ELEMENTARY ARTS
EDUCATION. THE PEDAGOGY REQUIRED
FOR CHILDREN AGES 4 TO 12 IS NOT
EQUIVALENT TO ENERGY
APPLICATION, DANCE, MUSIC,
THEATER, AND VISUAL ARTS.
CREDENTIAL TEACHERS ARE HIGHLY
QUALIFIED, THE VISUAL AND
PERFORMING ARTS ARE SINGLED OUT.
THERE'S NO NEED TO ESTABLISH A
NEW CREDENTIAL PATHWAY FOR
ELEMENTARY ARTS EDUCATION
OUTSIDE OF TRADITIONAL
CREDENTIALING, AS TWO ADDITIONAL
PATHWAYS CURRENTLY EXIST THE
SHORT TIME STAFF PERMIT AND THE
PROVISIONAL INTERN PERMIT. THEN
THEY TALK ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY
AND DEPARTMENT GENERAL
EDUCATION. DOES THAT GIVE YOU
ENOUGH TO MAYBE SPEAK TO WHAT
THEIR CONCERNS ARE? SURE, I IT
SOUNDS TO ME THAT THEIR CONCERNS
ARE RELATED TO THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE CURRENTLY PATHWAYS FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO EARN THE
AUTHORIZATION TO TEACH IN THIS
ELEMENTARY SETTING FOR ARTS,
MUSIC, THEATER AND DANCE, AND
THAT THOSE PATHWAYS EXIST
THROUGH, FULL TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS, OR ADDED
AUTHORIZATIONS THAT INVOLVE 20
UNITS OR MORE OF COURSEWORK. SO
IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE THEY'RE,
REFERRING TO THE EXISTING
PATHWAYS BEING APPROPRIATE AND
ACCEPTABLE TO SERVE IN THESE
SETTINGS. OKAY. AND I THINK
THERE'S ONE QUESTION THAT'S IN
OUR PACKET. AND THE INTERESTING
THING THIS IS VERY INTERESTING
STAFF REPORT BECAUSE WHILE WE
WERE TRYING TO GET AT THE ARTS,
IT REALLY LISTED ALL THE
DIFFERENT SUBJECTS WHERE THERE'S
SHORTFALLS IN HAVING TEACHERS
THAT ARE CREDENTIALED AND ABLE
TO TEACH THOSE SUBJECTS. AND,
AND I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW TO
ASK THIS QUESTION, BUT IS THIS A
FUNCTION OF THE OVERALL TEACHER
SHORTAGE OR IS THE OVERALL
TEACHER SHORTAGE LESS ACUTE? BUT
IT'S PARTICULARLY ACUTE IN
CERTAIN SUBJECT MATTER AREAS, I
THINK YOU COULD ARGUE BOTH, I
BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE READY FOR
ELECTED OFFICE. YOU KNOW, I
BELIEVE THAT THE OVERALL TEACHER
SHORTAGE IS DEFINITELY IMPACTING
ALL, CONTENT AREAS THAT WE'RE
SEEING ACROSS THE BOARD, HOWEVER
, CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION,
WHERE INDIVIDUALS ARE COMING
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR CAN
SOMETIMES BE, INCREASE OUSLY
IMPACTED, AS WELL, WHEN WE DON'T
SEE LEAS OFFERING SPECIFIC
COURSES SUCH AS ARTS, MUSIC,
THEATER AND DANCE, THEN WE SEE
INSTANCES WHERE THEY'RE NOT ABLE
TO RECRUIT THOSE TEACHERS
BECAUSE INDIVIDUALS AREN'T
SEEKING THAT PATHWAY FOR
CREDENTIALING. SO, IT'S KIND OF
A IF YOU BUILD IT, THEY WILL
COME, TYPE OF MENTALITY WHERE
IF, YOU KNOW, INDIVIDUALS AREN'T
ABLE TO FIND A JOB IN A CERTAIN
CONTENT AREA, THEY MIGHT SEEK A
CREDENTIAL THAT AUTHORIZES
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. SO INSTEAD
OF SEEKING THAT ART CREDENTIAL,
THEY MIGHT BE OBTAINING AN
ENGLISH CREDENTIAL BECAUSE THEY
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OBTAIN FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT IN THE ARTS. AND THEN
LET ME JUST ASK THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST TO SORT OF TALK ABOUT
WHAT YOUR ANALYSIS WAS, BECAUSE
YOU WANTED US TO CONSIDER THE
TRADE OFFS IN THIS. AND MAYBE
THIS PREVIOUS DISCUSSION HAS
BEEN A GOOD TEE UP FOR WHAT THE
TRADE OFFS MIGHT BE. IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS, IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S A PARTICULAR CONCERN
ABOUT PROPOSITION 28, ESPECIALLY
POTENTIALLY INCREASING A
SHORTFALL THAT COULD HAPPEN
WITHIN THE ARTS AND MUSIC AND
ENTERTAINMENT SPACE. I THINK IN
IN GENERAL, WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT,
YES, THAT MIGHT BE A ONE TIME
IMMEDIATE EFFECT, BUT OVER TIME,
THERE ARE THESE EXISTING
PATHWAYS IN WHICH FOLKS CAN
BECOME CREDENTIALED ART
TEACHERS. OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT PERHAPS IN CREATING A NEW
PATHWAY, IT LOWERS THE BARRIERS
OF ENTRY FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
DON'T WANT TO BE FULL FLEDGED
TEACHERS, BUT JUST HAVE A
PARTICULAR INTEREST IN ARTS AND
MUSIC, AND THEY WOULD FIND THIS
PARTICULAR PATHWAY, SOMETHING
THAT JUST FITS THAT PARTICULAR
INTEREST THAT THEY HAVE, AS
OPPOSED TO GOING AND GETTING A
SINGLE CREDENTIAL AND DOING,
ADDITIONAL WORK, BEYOND WHAT
THEY'RE INTERESTED IN DOING. BUT
AGAIN, WITH REGARDS TO THIS
PARTICULAR SHORTFALL, I THINK AS
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA, THERE IS
AN ART SHORTFALL, BUT THERE ARE
SHORTFALLS IN OTHER SUBJECT
AREAS THAT ARE MORE PRONOUNCED.
AND I, I THINK IT'S ALSO A
QUESTION OF COMPARING, AS WE'VE
HEARD AS WELL, THE CONCERN ABOUT
IT TAKES A PARTICULAR SKILL SET
AND ALSO KNOWLEDGE TO TEACH
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND EARLY
CHILDHOOD STUDENTS TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THEY LEARN AND TO, CREATE A
COURSE, A COURSE THAT, IS BASED
OFF OF THAT COGNITIVE ABILITY,
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS
PROPOSAL RELATIVE TO THE
EXISTING STANDARDS, IS IT ENOUGH
CREDITS THAT WE'RE REQUIRING,
AND ALSO THE CREDITS AREN'T
NECESSARILY TIED TO LIKE A
SPECIFIC, PROGRAM OR COURSEWORK.
IT'S UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL TO
KIND OF SELECT, WELL, WHICH
COURSEWORK DO I WANT TO DO THAT
COMPLIES WITH THIS BROADER
REQUIREMENT WHERE EXISTING
PROGRAMS, THEY ALREADY KIND OF
HAVE LIKE A STRUCTURED AND
PACKAGED, PROGRAM THAT'S
SPECIFIC TO AND CATERS TO THIS
PARTICULAR FIELD. OKAY. SENATOR
WILK, DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
HERE? I DON'T HAVE A QUESTION. I
JUST HAVE A I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT, ONE, I WAS A SUPPORTER
OF PROP 28. I SPENT MY ENTIRE
LEGISLATIVE CAREER ON THE JOINT
COMMITTEE OF THE ARTS. TO ME,
THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN GOING
THROUGH THE POLICY PROCESS. NOT
NOT A BUDGET TRAILER BILL. AND
I'M FRUSTRATED WITH THAT BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
GET IT RIGHT. AND SO NO, NO
QUESTIONS. REALLY. JUST AS
EXCITED AS I WAS ABOUT THE LAST,
LAST PRESENTATION, THIS ONE I
FIND FRUSTRATING BECAUSE AGAIN,
I JUST DON'T THINK IT'S BEEN
VETTED ENOUGH. AND THERE ARE
SERIOUS QUESTIONS. AND WE'RE
JUST GOING TO, YOU KNOW, PLOW
FORWARD AND HOPE IT WORKS. AND I
DON'T THINK THAT'S HOW WE SHOULD
BE DOING THINGS. BUT I KNOW
THAT'S NOT ON YOU. WELL, I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS, AND
I'M NOT BEING FLIP IN SAYING
THAT BECAUSE I THINK IT THAT'S
SORT OF A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT WE
PICKED UP IN THE LETTERS. AND I
JUST THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
LITTLE MORE DISCUSSION ABOUT
THIS AND WHAT THE RIGHT WAY IS
TO PROCEED, BECAUSE WE KNOW
BECAUSE THE VOTERS APPROVED THE
MEASURE, WE WILL PROCEED, AND
WE'RE AND, OF COURSE, ONE OF THE
ITEMS, I MEAN, THE NEXT TWO
ITEMS ARE REALLY RELATED TO THIS
STREAMLINING, CREDENTIALING, AND
THEN THE ISSUE OF THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHERS PROGRAM AND
TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE INTO
TEACHING. SO, WE'RE JUST GOING
TO HAVE TO CONSIDER THIS ALSO IN
THE CONTEXT OF THESE OTHER ITEMS
AND HOW WE MOVE PEOPLE INTO
TEACHING. SO I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AND KNOW THAT THIS IS
ANOTHER ONE THAT SOUNDS LIKE
IT'S GOING TO GO TILL THE END OF
THE BUDGET. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY. WE
APPRECIATE IT. AND THEN, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE TEACHER
CREDENTIAL CREDENTIALING
STREAMLINING AND WE HAVE THE
RETURN PANELISTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND RETURN
PANELISTS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYSTS AND WE HAVE DAVID
DEGOOYER FROM THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. AND WE
HAVE A STRONG SUPPORT PERSON
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE RECEDED NEXT TO MISS SABAH.
SO LET'S GO THROUGH IN THAT SAME
ORDER. WE'LL START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MEGAN
SABAH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
2021 AND 2022 BUDGET ACTS
PROVIDED NUMEROUS MULTIYEAR
INVESTMENTS TO BETTER PREPARE,
TRAIN, RECRUIT, RECRUIT AND
RETAIN A DIVERSE, EXPERT
WORKFORCE OF ADMINISTRATIVE,
CREDENTIALED, AND CLASSIFIED
STAFF IN CALIFORNIA'S K-12
SCHOOLS. SO WHILE WE ARE
BEGINNING TO SEE EVIDENCE THAT
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE PAYING
OFF, STAFFING SHORTAGES CONTINUE
TO PERSIST. TO THIS END, THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
NON-FISCAL CHANGES TO STREAMLINE
PROCESSES AND REDUCE COSTS FOR
WELL QUALIFIED TEACHER
CANDIDATES TO EARN A CREDENTIAL.
THESE CHANGES INCLUDE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO EXPLICITLY
EXEMPT CREDENTIAL APPLICANTS
WITH A BACHELOR'S DEGREE OR
HIGHER FROM A REGIONALLY
ACCREDITED INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION FROM THE BASIC SKILLS
REQUIREMENT. THERE ARE ALSO A
NUMBER OF CODE SECTIONS THAT
CLEAN UP STATUTE TO REMOVE
REFERENCE TO BASIC SKILLS
PROFICIENCY LANGUAGE WHERE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE OR HIGHER IS
REQUIRED, THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FURTHER PROPOSES A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE, DIRECTING THE
COMMISSION TO ENSURE THAT
SUBJECT MATTER DOMAINS ARE
ALIGNED FOR COURSEWORK REVIEW.
ADDITIONALLY THE LANGUAGE
ENCOURAGES THE COMMISSION TO
EXCUSE ME TO LEVERAGE ITS
ACCREDITATION SYSTEM TO ENSURE
PROGRAMS UTILIZE TRANSCRIPT
REVIEW FOR ASSESSMENT OF SUBJECT
MATTER COMPETENCE. THIS
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE'LL MOVE TO THE
COMMISSION. WELCOME FROM
DIRECTOR OF, PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES DIVISION AT THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. THANK YOU, AT
ITS, JUNE MEETING LAST YEAR, THE
COMMISSION HEARD A REPORT, AN
ANNUAL REPORT ON THE EXAMINATION
PROGRAM AND THE COMMISSIONERS
DISCUSSED, IN PARTICULAR, THE
VALUE OF THE CBEST EXAM. AND
THEY WERE VERY CLEAR THAT THEY
THOUGHT IT DID NOT PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL VALUE IN DETERMINING
WHO WAS CLASSROOM READY. SO
COMMISSIONERS VERY MUCH SUPPORT,
THE PROPOSAL TO ALLOW A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE TO MEET BASIC
SKILLS REQUIREMENT, IN OUR
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE, OUR,
WE SAID THAT ONE THING THAT WE
COULD DO WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WAS TO CREATE A SECOND
SET OF SUBJECT MATTER
REQUIREMENTS AT THE DOMAIN
LEVEL. SO AT THE TOP LEVEL THAT
ARE CLEAR AND CONSISTENT FOR
PREPARATION PROGRAMS TO USE,
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THEY LOOK
DIFFERENT FROM SUBJECT TO
SUBJECT. SO WE HAVE STARTED THAT
WORK. IT'S TAKING A LITTLE
LONGER THAN WE THOUGHT, BUT WE
STILL HOPE TO HAVE THAT FINISHED
IN JUNE. THANK YOU. NOW WE'LL
MOVE TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST.
IN OUR ASSESSMENT OF THE
PROPOSAL, WE DID FIND THAT FOR
THE BASIC SKILLS REQUIREMENT, IT
DID SEEM TO CREATE, IN SOME
CASES, UNNECESSARY BARRIERS FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE ALREADY IN
THE TEACHING FIELD. THEY JUST
HAD THAT ONE REQUIREMENT LEFT
HAVE PROVED THEMSELVES TO BE
EFFECTIVE TEACHERS, BUT THEY
WERE STRUGGLING IN MEETING THAT
REQUIREMENT, ADDITIONALLY, AS IT
RELATES TO THE TRANSCRIPT REVIEW
PROCESS, WE DID REVIEW THE CTC
REPORT AND THEY DID PROVIDE
EXAMPLES OF HOW IT IS A COMPLEX
AND BURDENSOME PROCESS.
CURRENTLY AND IT COULD BE
STREAMLINED THROUGH THE
RECOMMENDED CHANGES. SO WITH
THAT SAID, WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVE THE TWO
PROPOSED CHANGES. THANK YOU.
THAT'S VERY PLEASANT UNITY. AND
NORMALLY I SHOULD HAVE THE SENSE
ENOUGH TO MOVE ON IMMEDIATELY,
BUT I THINK THE ONE QUESTION I
WOULD HAVE HERE, BECAUSE WE HAVE
THIS IN FRONT OF US RIGHT NOW,
IS THAT I HEAR COMPLAINTS ALL
THE TIME FROM THERE'S A TEACHER
SHORTAGE AND PEOPLE, IT COSTS
THEM EXTRA MONEY. IT HAS ALL
THIS PROCESS. IT TAKES AGES FOR
THEM TO GET CREDENTIALED AT A
TIME WHEN WE'RE NEARING A CRISIS
IN, IN THE NUMBER OF TEACHERS.
AND YET AT THE SAME TIME, WE
HAVE THE DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
CORE COMPETENCIES THAT ACTUALLY
NEED TO BE PRESENT FOR A TEACHER
TO BE THERE IN THE CLASSROOM. SO
HOW DO YOU BALANCE THAT? BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THIS ITEM IS ALL
ABOUT, IS THAT BALANCE. HOW DO
YOU MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE SORT
OF TEST TO MAKE SURE A TEACHER
IS REALLY QUALIFIED TO MOVE IN.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE DON'T
HAVE SO MANY BARRIERS THAT WE
CAN'T EVEN GET TO THAT THAT
POINT. AND I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE
WE'LL START WITH THE COMMISSION.
SO I THINK MAYBE 130, WAS. I
THINK AB 130 WAS A HUGE STEP
FORWARD IN HELPING THE STATE
RETHINK THE VALUE AND THE PLACE
OF STANDARDIZED EXAMINATIONS,
AND BY ALLOWING CANDIDATES TO
DEMONSTRATE THEIR BASIC SKILLS,
PROFICIENCY AND THEIR SUBJECT
MATTER COMPETENCE THROUGH
COURSEWORK THEY'VE ALREADY DONE,
YOU KNOW, THE HOPE WAS THAT IT
WOULD SAVE MONEY AND TIME FOR
CANDIDATES. AND IT CERTAINLY HAS
HAD THAT EFFECT FOR MANY
CANDIDATES, BUT NOT AS MANY, I
THINK, AS WE ALL WOULD HAVE
HOPED, IT IT HAS BEEN OUR
EXPERIENCE THAT THE BASIC SKILLS
HAS BEEN EASIER FOR OUR
PREPARATION PROGRAMS TO REVIEW,
COURSEWORK FOR THOSE MEETING
THAT THAT THE BASIC SKILLS
REQUIREMENT BUT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT IN THE AREA OF SUBJECT
MATTER. SO WE THINK THAT THE,
THE BACHELOR'S DEGREE FOR
MEETING BASIC SKILLS IS A CLEAR
STEP FORWARD FOR EVERYONE, IT
MAKES SENSE AND IT WILL SAVE
CANDIDATES TIME AND MONEY AND
PREPARATION PROGRAMS. TIME AND
MONEY, WITH SUBJECT MATTER IN
OUR REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
LAST NOVEMBER, WE SAID THAT, YOU
KNOW, PROBABLY THE BEST SOLUTION
WOULD BE TO HAVE A STATEWIDE
LIST OF COURSES THAT MEET THE
SUBJECT MATTER DOMAINS FOR EACH
SUBJECT. BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE TIME AND
MONEY. SO IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN TAKE ON OURSELVES
RIGHT NOW. BUT BUT AS THE LAO
SUGGESTED IN LOOKING AT OUT
YEARS WHEN MONEY MAY BECOME
AVAILABLE, THAT THAT MIGHT BE A
KEY THING TO LOOK AT. GREAT ANY
COMMENTS, LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO ADD?
OKAY, THEN LET ME DOUBLE CHECK.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT, I THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT. WE ALL KNOW THERE'S A
MÁS A PRETTY SIZABLE TEACHER
SHORTAGE AND STAFF SHORTAGE. SO
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO EXPEDITE
THAT, I THINK THIS IS EVEN IN A
TIME OF BUDGET CRISIS. I THINK
THIS IS A WORTHWHILE INVESTMENT.
GREAT. SENATOR WILK, OKAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I THINK WE
MANAGED TO REALLY GET AT THIS IN
THE IN THE BRIEF AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT IT. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE LAST ISSUE.
WE HAVE OF THE SEVEN ISSUES, THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM, AND WE HAVE IMAN SINGH
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
CHRIS FERGUSON IS ALSO GOING TO
BE HERE. I THINK HE JUST WALKED
IN. HE'S HIS MAGIC. ON KNOWING
HOW TO MAKE AN ENTRANCE. AND
THEN MADISON, SHEFFIELD AGAIN
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND AGAIN, MISS ROCIO
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. LET'S START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WELCOME
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR LAIRD AND
MEMBERS. I'M AMAN SINGH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I'LL BE PROVIDING A
SUMMARY OF THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ESTIMATES THAT
ROUGHLY 7500 GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT AWARDS WILL BE
PROVIDED TO STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
TEACHER PREPARATORY PROGRAMS IN
THE 2425 ACADEMIC YEAR. THE
TOTAL AWARD PACKAGE FOR 2425
AMOUNTS TO 134 MILLION. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PRESENTED A POINT IN TIME
ESTIMATE, AND THE SPECIFIC
NUMBER OF RECIPIENTS AND THE
UPDATED TOTAL AWARD AMOUNT WILL
BE CALCULATED AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION. THIS UPDATE WILL
INCLUDE A MORE ACCURATE STUDENT
CASELOAD ACCOUNT FOR SOME BRIEF
BACKGROUND, THE 2122 BUDGET ACT
PROVIDED $500 MILLION IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM.
THIS WAS INTENDED TO BE SPENT
OVER THE COURSE OF FIVE YEARS.
THE PROGRAM WILL REACH ITS
EXPECTED EXPIRATION IN 2526. FOR
CONTEXT, WE'RE CURRENTLY IN YEAR
THREE OF FIVE OF THE EXPENDITURE
PERIOD. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOES NOT PROPOSE ANY FUNDING
CHANGES TO THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM. IT'S
ESSENTIALLY LEFT UNCHANGED
DESPITE THE STATE'S CURRENT
FISCAL POSITION. THE BUDGET
INDICATES THAT THE ENTIRETY OF
THE INITIAL $500 MILLION
ALLOCATION WILL REACH ITS
INTENDED RECIPIENTS. THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. I'LL TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE COMMISSION.
MADISON, SHEFFIELD, CALIFORNIA
STUDENT COMMISSION I DON'T HAVE
ANY SPECIFIC COMMENTS. THE
AGENDA GOES DOES THOROUGH
BACKGROUND AND MY COLLEAGUE
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL BACKGROUND.
SO IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS,
HAPPY TO ANSWER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST, AS
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA, IN JANUARY
2024 AND OUR INITIAL ASSESSMENT,
WE ESTIMATED THAT ABOUT $220
MILLION OF GOLDEN STATE, TEACHER
GRANT FUNDS REMAINED UNSPENT,
AND THEN BASED OFF OF CURRENT
AWARD TRENDS AT THAT TIME WE
ESTIMATED THAT AT THE END OF THE
CURRENT YEAR 2324, WE COULD
EXPECT ABOUT $130 MILLION TO
STILL REMAIN UNSPENT. OF COURSE,
THIS IS A MULTI YEAR, PROGRAM.
SO THAT'S NOT AN ISSUE. BUT
GIVEN THE PROJECTED BUDGET
DEFICIT, WE DO RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER,
PULLING BACK ANY UNSPENT
DOLLARS, NOT JUST IN THIS
PROGRAM BUT ACROSS, VARIOUS ONE
TIME MULTI YEAR PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LET ME ASK FIRST
IF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR.
MAN. OKAY. THANKS OKAY THEN LET
ME ASK. AND I APPRECIATE WHAT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST JUST
SAID ABOUT PULLING BACK, BUT
THIS APPEARS TO BE A PROGRAM
THAT HAS REALLY WORKED. AND ONE
THING THAT WAS UNCLEAR FROM THE
CHARTS THAT WAS JUST ASSUMED IS
THAT IF SOMEBODY GETS THIS,
THEY'RE COMMITTED TO DO TEACHING
OR FOLLOW UP. AND SO WE JUST
ASSUME THAT'S HAPPENING WITH
EVERY ONE HERE OR THEY HAVE TO
PAY IT BACK. IS THAT RIGHT? DO
WE KNOW IF MANY PEOPLE HAVE PAID
IT BACK OR THIS IS JUST REALLY,
TRULY A PATHWAY FOR ALMOST
EVERYBODY THAT GETS A GRANT INTO
THE SYSTEM? DO WE KNOW THAT
MADISON SHEFFIELD CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION, GIVEN
THAT WE'RE ONLY A FEW YEARS INTO
THE PROGRAM AND IT TAKES PEOPLE,
STUDENTS ABOUT A YEAR OR TWO
YEARS APPROXIMATELY TO COMPLETE
THEIR ACTUAL TEACHING CREDENTIAL
, WHICH THEY INITIALLY GET THE
MONEY TO SUPPORT THEM IN
TEACHING, IN OBTAINING THE
CREDENTIAL. AND THEN THEY HAVE
EIGHT YEARS TO COMPLETE, FOUR
YEARS OF SERVICE AND DO THE
ACTUAL, SERVICE COMPONENT. SO
GIVEN THAT WE'RE ONLY 2 OR 3
YEARS INTO THE PROGRAM, WE JUST
HAVE SUCH LIMITED DATA ON ON IF
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE PAYING
BACK. I THINK, YOU KNOW,
HOPEFULLY IT'S VERY RARE THAT
PEOPLE DON'T COMPLETE THE
SERVICE REQUIREMENT. BUT, WE
HAVE WE HAVE VERY, VERY LIMITED
DATA THAT I CAN GET YOU, BUT
IT'S JUST SO LIMITED THAT WE
CAN'T MAKE ANY KIND OF GRAND
PROJECTIONS ON HOW MANY AND THEN
THE OTHER QUESTION THAT WAS
UNCLEAR TO ME WAS, WAS WHAT WE
HAVE, WHAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IN THE PREVIOUS ITEMS, THE
SHORTAGE OF TEACHERS, HOW DO WE
MATCH THE NUMBERS IN THIS
PROGRAM AGAINST WHAT THE
SHORTAGE OF TEACHERS IS? I MEAN,
ARE THERE BUNCHES OF TEACHERS
THAT ARE ABLE TO DO THIS WITHOUT
GETTING A GRANT FROM THIS
PROGRAM? AND SO WE HAVE A COHORT
THERE, AND THEN WE HAVE THE
COHORT HERE. HOW ARE WE DOING
AGAINST THE VACANCIES THAT ARE
CREATED OR THE MISSED
ASSIGNMENTS THAT ARE MISSING
WITH WHAT'S THE RESULTS OF THIS
PROGRAM? I CAN SIMPLY COMMENT
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE ADMINISTER
JUST THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER
GRANT PROGRAM. AND THEN OF
COURSE, THE CAL GRANT AND MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP. I WOULD I
WOULD LIKELY DEFER TO COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING BECAUSE
THEY DO WE DO WORK WITH THEM FOR
THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
DATA. WE DO PARTNER WITH THEM.
SO THEY WOULD PROBABLY BE HAVE
THE LENS THAT THEY COULD THEY
COULD LINE UP MORE ACCURATELY.
WE DON'T HAVE THE FULL LENS ON
ALL THAT ARE GETTING THE
TEACHING CREDENTIAL AND HOW MANY
OF THOSE ARE SUPPORTED BY GTG
VERSUS OTHER PROGRAMS, THAT
WOULD BE MY ADVICE. DO YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENT? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? I DON'T HAVE THE
FIGURES IN FRONT OF ME, BUT I
DID DO A ROUGH CALCULATION THAT
THROUGH 23, 24 OR 2425, LIKE
OVER 20,000 RECIPIENTS OF THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM WILL BE ON THEIR WAY TO
TEACHING. SO I DON'T KNOW HOW
THAT COMPARES TO THE TOTAL
DEFICIT OF TEACHERS ACROSS THE
STATE. BUT THIS IS THIS PROGRAM
IS REACHING A LOT OF AWARDEES.
AND DOES THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
HAPPEN TO HAVE A COMMENT HERE, I
THINK ONE THING THAT WE WOULD
FLAG IS THAT, DATA FOR FUTURE
EVALUATION MAY BE LIMITED, JUST
GIVEN THE PARAMETERS OF THE
PROGRAM, FOR EXAMPLE, TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT, ARE WE ABLE TO
MAP OUT, DID DID A GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT RECIPIENT BECOME A
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER?
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THAT'S BEEN
A LONG STANDING SHORTAGE AREA.
WE MAY NOT NECESSARILY HAVE THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE INITIALLY
THE PROGRAM. YES, DID REQUIRE
THAT INDIVIDUALS, SERVE ARE
TEACHING IN A SHORTAGE FIELD.
BUT THEN THAT WAS LATER REMOVED.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT, IT'S NOT
AN EXISTING PROGRAM REQUIREMENT,
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT, THE
ABILITY OR, COLLECTING THAT
INFORMATION MAY NOT BE
OCCURRING. SO IT WAS REMOVED AS
A REQUIREMENT. BUT IT SEEMS THAT
THEN WHAT WAS ALSO REMOVED IS
THE ABILITY TO KNOW WHERE THEY
REALLY WENT, I WOULD DEFER TO
THE, TO CSAC ON WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S AN ABILITY TO MAP OUT
REGIONALLY WHERE THEY WENT. THE
PRIORITY SCHOOL REQUIREMENT IS
STILL THERE, AND THAT WAS OUR
ATTEMPT TO ENSURE AND WHAT I
MEAN BY WHERE THEY WENT WAS
PROBABLY INARTICULATELY ASKED,
BUT IF THEY WENT TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION, WHICH WAS A HIGH
NEED, EVEN THOUGH IT WAS, TAKEN
BACK AS A MANDATE, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT,
POTENTIALLY THAT'S NOT CURRENTLY
BEING COLLECTED ON A SUBJECT
MATTER BASIS IN TERMS OF WHERE
THEY WENT. WE CAN MAP OUT WHAT
SCHOOLS THEY WENT TO BECAUSE
THAT IS A REQUIREMENT THAT THEY
SERVE IN A. BUT IF WE HAVE A
DEFICIT DUE TO MISSED
ASSIGNMENT, WE'RE NOT MEASURING
WHETHER THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER
PROGRAM IS LEADING TO ADDRESSING
THE MISSED ASSIGNMENT PROBLEM
FOR DEFICITS IN CERTAIN SUBJECT
MATTERS THAT MAY NOT BE
COLLECTED INTERNALLY WITHIN THIS
PROGRAM. I THINK THEN THERE'S A
QUESTION OF CAN WE DO SOME DATA
MATCHING? THERE'S A SEMI ANXIOUS
COMMISSION STAFFER STANDING IN
THE BACK HERE AND I DON'T KNOW,
DOES THAT MICROPHONE WORK? IF HE
WALKS UP TO IT? OH HERE WE GO.
NOT SEMI ANXIOUS. JUST WANTED TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT THERE
CURRENTLY IS A BILL BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE, SENATE BILL 1391
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE CSAC THE
COMMISSION AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE DATA TO THE CRADLE TO
CAREER OFFICE OF THE CRADLE TO
CAREER DATA SYSTEM. SO THAT THAT
TRACKING COULD BE DONE. AND I
ASSUME THAT BILL COSTS MONEY. I
DON'T KNOW THAT IT DOES BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, WE COLLECT SOME DATA,
SOME OF THE DATA THAT YOU WOULD
NEED TO DO THE ANALYSIS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. CSAC HAS SOME OF
THE DATA CDC HAS SOME OF THE
DATA. SO I'M NOT SURE THAT THE
BILL ASKS THAT ADDITIONAL DATA
BE COLLECTED. IT'S MORE THAT IT
ALL REQUIRES THAT EXISTING DATA
BE TRANSMITTED. YEAH. TO THE
CRADLE TO CAREER SYSTEM SO THAT
THOSE KIND OF ANALYZES COULD BE
RUN. OKAY. I SIT ON THAT BOARD.
SO MAYBE I'LL SEE ABOUT ASKING
THE QUESTION COMING THE OTHER
WAY. I SIT ON THAT BOARD AS
WELL. WE LOVE TO HAVE YOU. YEAH.
WELL, I'D LOVE TO NOT BE
CHAIRING A HEARING AND BE ABLE
TO ATTEND MORE, SO THANK YOU.
THAT'S REALLY HELPFUL. AND I
THINK THAT THAT OVER TIME IS
ALSO INFORMATION WE'D REALLY
LIKE TO KNOW. FAR BE IT FOR ME
TO SUGGEST SOMETHING THAT COSTS
SOMETHING THIS YEAR. BUT IF IT
CAN BE SWEPT IN A WAY THAT IT IS
COLLECTED BUT JUST NOT
TRANSMITTED AT, AND THERE'S
TRANSMITTING GOING ON ANYWAY,
THAT'S A VERY MINIMAL COST, IF
ANY. SO JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
THAT OUT, BECAUSE WE AT THE, AT
THE HIGH LEVEL GET ASKED HOW WE
ADDRESSING THE TEACHER SHORTAGE,
ARE WE ADDRESSING IT WHERE IT
REALLY NEEDS. AND HAVING SOME OF
THAT INFORMATION WOULD ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS FOR US. JUST TO
MADISON SHEFFIELD STUDENT
COMMISSION, JUST TO CLARIFY, WE
DEFINITELY CURRENTLY HAVE TO
COLLECT DATA RELATED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAM.
SO WE KNOW, HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
GETTING CREDENTIALS. AND THEN WE
ALSO KNOW WHERE THEY'RE WORKING,
WHICH ONES ARE WORKING PRIORITY
SCHOOLS. IF THEY DON'T WORK IN A
PRIORITY SCHOOL, THEY HAVE TO
GIVE THE MONEY BACK. SO WE DO
KNOW AS THE DATA COMES IN AND AS
STUDENTS ACTUALLY WORK IN PRIORY
SCHOOLS, WE WILL KNOW WHERE THEY
ARE WORKING AND IF THEY'RE
WORKING IN PRIORITY SCHOOLS. SO
JUST TO CLARIFY, THAT PIECE, AND
LET ME ASK A FINANCE ONE OTHER
QUESTION, THEN, WILL THE
EXISTING MONEY BE EXHAUSTED BY
JULY 1ST OR IS THERE GOING TO BE
SOME CARRY OVER MONEY OR OTHER
MONEY THAT MIGHT HELP IN THE
BUDGET YEAR WITH THIS? I'M I'M
SYNCING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BASED ON THE ESTIMATES
THAT WE RECEIVED AT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. WE ARE ESTIMATING THAT
MOST OF THE FUNDING WILL BE
EXHAUSTED BY 2425, YOU KNOW,
WHEN WE WERE DEVELOPING THE
BUDGET IN THE FALL, WE WERE
ANTICIPATING THAT SOME FUNDS MAY
BE REMAINING IN 25, 26. HOWEVER,
CSAC IS CURRENTLY TRACKING A
REALLY HIGH APPLICATION RATE,
AND IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THOSE
FUNDS MAY BE EXHAUSTED BY THE
END OF 2425. WE WILL BE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE COMMISSION
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
MOST ACCURATE STUDENT CASELOAD
COUNT FOR THE MAY REVISION, BUT
AS OF THIS TIME, IT'S LOOKING
LIKE MOST OF THE FUNDING WILL BE
EXHAUSTED BY THE END OF THE 2425
ACADEMIC YEAR, WHICH IS ABOUT A
YEAR EARLIER THAN WE EXPECTED AT
THE PROGRAMS, ESTABLISHMENT AND
MR. FERGUSON, DID YOU HAVE
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD, OR DO
YOU JUST WANT TO GO ON THE
RECORD FOR NODDING THE WAY YOU
WERE AT EVERYTHING SHE SAID? I
WOULD, GO ON THE RECORD. CHRIS
FERGUSON FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND JUST AGREE WITH,
WITH WHAT MISS SINGH HAD SAID,
BASED ON OUR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROJECTIONS, THERE WAS A SMALL
AMOUNT THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE
IN 25, 26. HOWEVER WE UPLOAD OR
WE UPDATE CASELOAD AT THE MAY
REVISION. SO IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
THAT PROJECTION WILL CHANGE.
OKAY. I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION. AND OF COURSE, WE
DUCKED THE MAJOR ISSUE TO LAST
ABOUT WHAT TO DO ABOUT THE MONEY
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT REALLY HOW IT
WORKS. AND I WOULD SAY WE REALLY
LIKE THIS PROGRAM AND BELIEVE
THAT IT WORKS AND BELIEVES THAT
THAT WE NEED THIS AS PART OF
WHAT WE DO TO MAKE SURE WE
ADDRESS THE TEACHER SHORTAGE.
BUT WE RECOGNIZE WHERE WE ARE
THIS YEAR AND THAT WE MIGHT HAVE
TO LOOK AT THAT IN THE WHOLE
PICTURE WHEN IT GETS THERE. LET
ME DO A LAST CALL. ANY LAST
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OR COMMENTS? JUST ONE COMMENT. I
NOTICED THAT YOU DID NOT ENFORCE
YOUR NO. ACKERMAN, NO. NO. DICK
ACKERMAN RULE. NO NO NO NO NO,
I'M HAVING A SENIOR MOMENT,
DON'T SAY THAT. YOU'RE YOUNGER
THAN ME. ACRONYM IS WHAT YOU
MEANT TO SAY. YOU DIDN'T ENFORCE
IT TODAY. OH, I ENFORCED IT A
LOT OF TIMES. BUT YOU WEREN'T
HERE WHEN OAN WHEN WE HAD THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION, AND I
SAID THAT THE COUNTY SUPERVISORS
HAVE THE SAME ACRONYM. AND IT'S
ALWAYS CONFUSING TO ME WHY THEY
HAVE SUCH A STRONG POSITION ON
STUDENT AID, YOU KNOW? SO, OKAY,
I DON'T NOT SEEING ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. I THINK WE HAD A GOOD
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS. WE
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES THAT ARE
ON THE TABLE AS WE CLOSE THIS
OUT. SO THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PANEL.
THAT COMPLETES THE HEARING OF
THE SEVEN ISSUES WE HAD TODAY.
AND WE, HAVE TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND LET ME JUST TAKE AN
INFORMAL POLL. WHO'S SITTING
HERE WANTS TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT. 123, FOUR, FIVE PEOPLE.
THEN I WILL ALLOW UP TO TWO
MINUTES EACH AND ASK THE FIVE
PEOPLE TO LINE UP HERE AT THE
PODIUM AND ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
WITH YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. I CAN'T TELL WHETHER IT'S
STILL MORNING OR IF IT'S
AFTERNOON NOW. IT'S STILL
MORNING. BUT IF YOU ALL RUN
OVER, WILL BE IN THE AFTERNOON.
I WON'T, I WON'T BE LONG. MY
NAME IS MARTHA ZARAGOZA DIAZ,
AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING MR.
CHAD ZULLINGER, WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUSIC EDUCATORS ASSOCIATION, AND
HAD TO LEAVE BECAUSE HE TEACHES
MUSIC CLASSES AND HE NEEDED TO
BE THERE ON TIME. ANYWAY, I
WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE, WELL,
FIRST OF ALL, I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR THE VERY DELIBERATE
DISCUSSION, AND COMPREHENSIVE
DISCUSSION THAT TOOK PLACE WITH
REGARDS TO THE CTE EDUCATION,
PROPOSAL. I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THERE IS NO NEED
TO ESTABLISH A NEW AUTHORIZATION
OR CREDENTIAL IN ADDRESSING THE
ARTS TEACHER SHORTAGE, BECAUSE
CREDENTIALING OPTIONS ALREADY
EXIST, WHICH ARE FASTER WITH
REGARD TO, HAVING TRACKS TO
CERTIFICATION THÀNH. THESE
INCLUDE THE SHORT TERME STAFF
PERMIT, THE PROVISIONAL
INTERNSHIP PERMIT, AND THE
SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATION. THE
SECOND POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS
THAT THE CTE PROPOSAL UNDERMINES
SUBJECT MATTER COMPETENCY BY
ALLOWING THOSE WITH INDUSTRY
EXPERTISE IN THE ARTS TO TEACH
ELEMENTARY GRADES TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT PREPARATION. SUBJECT
MATTER COMPETENCY IS ESSENTIAL
FOR EFFECTIVE INSTRUCTION, AS IT
ALLOWS TEACHERS TO TEACH
FOUNDATIONAL SKILLS AND ENGAGE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL STUDENTS
THROUGH SOUND PEDAGOGICAL
PRINCIPLES. WITHOUT IT, TEACHERS
MAY STRUGGLE TO EXPLAIN
CONCEPTS, PROVIDE FEEDBACK TO
THE DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS OF OUR
YOUNGER STUDENTS. SUPPORT SECOND
LANGUAGE LEARNERS STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS. THUS LEADING
STUDENTS TO FALLING BEHIND AND
LOSING FOUNDATIONAL ARTS
KNOWLEDGE. CREDENTIAL ARTS
TEACHERS ARE HIGHLY QUALIFIED
EDUCATORS WITH THE COLLEGE
DEGREE AND AN EXPERTISE AND
TRAINING IN ARTS EDUCATION IN
THE ARTS FOR STUDENTS IN
TRANSITIONAL GARDEN THROUGH
GRADE 12. GIVEN THAT GIVEN THAT
THE INTENT OF PROP 28 IS TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO QUALITY ARTS
AND MUSIC EDUCATION FOR ALL
STUDENTS, WE BELIEVE THIS
PROPOSAL DETERS FROM THE SPIRIT
OF THE LAW BY LOWERING TEACHING
STANDARDS AND INSTRUCTIONAL
OUTCOMES FOR OUR STUDENTS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL STUDENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS, AND
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING, RAQUEL MORALES ON
BEHALF OF AT TRUST WEST, WE WANT
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
20 MILLION FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
AND DELIVERY OF FOR EDUCATOR
TRAINING ALIGNED WITH THE 2023
CALIFORNIA MATH FRAMEWORK. THIS
TRAINING IS CRITICAL TO
REALIZING THE FULL BENEFITS OF
THE NEW FRAMEWORK AND CHANGING
THE WAY WE THINK ABOUT MATH AND
DELIVERY INSTRUCTION. THE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING WILL HELP
TEACHERS IMPROVE THEIR
STRATEGIES TO HELP MORE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS, AND MORE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL. ADDITIONALLY, WE ALSO
WANT TO SUPPORT OUR, EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE EXPANSION OF KGI
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO ALL NINTH
THROUGH 12TH GRADE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. HOUSING COLLEGE
RELATED PROCESSES UNDER ONE
PLATFORM CAN LEAD TO IMPROVED
FAMILY SUPPORTS BY COUNSELORS
AND INCREASED ACCESS FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES. FOR
EXAMPLE, KGI IS BEST POSITIONED
TO SUPPORT WITH IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE UNIVERSAL FINANCIAL AID
POLICY, SUPPORTING COUNSELORS
WITH INFORMATION ON STUDENTS
THAT HAVE COMPLETED THEIR
APPLICATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS AND STAFF, JEFF VOLKER,
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS. MY COMMENTS PERTAIN TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE, THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE GUIDANCE INITIATIVE,
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION HAS SERVED AS THE
FISCAL AGENT FOR THE PROGRAM
SINCE 2015. SO WE'VE HAD KIND OF
A UNIQUE VANTAGE POINT IN BEING
ABLE TO WITNESS NOT JUST THE
GROWTH IN THE PROGRAM, BUT THE
GROWTH AND THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PROGRAM, I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN EDUCATION ADVOCACY ON BOTH
THE HIGHER EDUCATION THÀNH AND
K-12 SIDE, FOR LONGER THAN I
WOULD CARE TO ADMIT AT THIS
JUNCTURE. AND THIS IS AN ISSUE.
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT REALLY, I
THINK GETS TO THE HEART OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAVE TAKEN
PLACE IN MANY INSTANCES IN THE
LEGISLATURE OVER THAT PERIOD
ABOUT ARTICULATION BETWEEN K-12
AND HIGHER EDUCATION, AS THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER NOTED, THE
SUPPORT AND THE ASSISTANCE THAT
IT PROVIDES, NOT JUST TO
STUDENTS, BUT THEIR FAMILIES AS
THEIR REALLY AS EARLY AS MIDDLE
SCHOOL, REALLY IS WORTH THE
INVESTMENT. ACKNOWLEDGING THE
FISCAL CHALLENGES THE STATE
FACES, IT DOES SOUND FROM THE
CONVERSATION THIS MORNING THAT
THERE IS A PATHWAY FORWARD, AND
WE JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU, HEATHER
CALOMYS WITH EDVOICE, REGARDING
THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM, IT IS CRITICAL THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO INVEST
IN PROGRAMS THAT ENSURE WELL
PREPARED TEACHERS OR STAFFED IN
THE HIGHEST NEED SCHOOLS TO
ENSURE STUDENTS FROM THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES HAVE
ACCESS TO EXPERIENCE AND
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS IN THEIR
CLASSROOMS. THEREFORE,
CALIFORNIA SHOULD CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN AND ACTUALLY
STRENGTHEN PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM TO ENSURE FUNDING IS
PRIORITIZED FOR TEACHER
CANDIDATES STAFFED IN THE
HIGHEST NEED. PUBLIC SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE. IN TERMS OF
THE LITERACY SCREENERS, AS WELL.
THE LACK OR DELAY IN SCREENING
OF STRUGGLING READERS AND
STUDENTS AT THE RISK OF DYSLEXIA
RESULTS IN UNNECESSARY DELAYS IN
RECEIVING THE APPROPRIATE
SUPPORT AND INTERVENTIONS DUE TO
THESE DELAYS, THE ACADEMIC GAP
AND LEARNING LOSS IN CORE
CONTENT IS OFTEN VERY DIFFICULT
TO OVERCOME, EVEN AFTER
SIGNIFICANT COSTS AND
INTERVENTIONS DOWN THE LINE.
THEREFORE WE URGE THE
IMPLEMENTATION TO MOVE FORWARD
AS WRITTEN IN THE 2025 2026
SCHOOL YEAR. SO THAT STUDENTS
CAN RECEIVE THE CRITICAL
SUPPORTS NEEDED TO ENSURE THEIR
SUCCESS AND THEIR READING
THROUGHOUT THEIR SCHOOL AGE,
TIME. THANK YOU, THANK YOU, DID
YOU WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT? I
JUST WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT. I
WANT TO THANK EDVOICE BECAUSE IT
WAS AT A CONFERENCE YOU GUYS
HELD THAT. THEN LET SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND I KNOW YOU KNOW
WHAT WAS GOING ON. AND I KNOW
WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO GET THAT
PASS, I CALLED OVER, TO YOUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND THANKED
HIM. BUT IF YOU COULD GO BACK TO
THE ENTIRE BOARD AND JUST LET
THEM KNOW THAT, YOU GUYS DO MAKE
A DIFFERENCE AND REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE EDUCATIONAL
TIME YOU YOU POUR INTO
LEGISLATORS. GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT
. I DON'T YOU SHOULD ALSO TELL
THEM THAT IT'S UNPRECEDENTED TO
LET A SENATOR INTERRUPT A PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND IT WAS ALLOWED,
BECAUSE THAT WAS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT COMMENT TO THE SENATOR
, HERE'S OUR HERE'S OUR LAST
SPEAKER, PLEASE. AND I WILL BE
BRIEF SIDE OF THE CHILDREN NOW
ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM EDVOICE ON THE
TEACHER ON THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM BECAUSE OF
ITS EFFECTIVENESS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE,
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT,
THAT COMPLETES, OUR BUSINESS,
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND I WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY THAT
PARTICIPATED TODAY, WHETHER A
PANELIST OR A MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC OR THOSE OF YOU WATCHING
OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. AND IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY,
LET ME REPEAT THAT. YOU CAN
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE. OR YOU CAN VISIT THE
WEBSITE AND MAKE COMMENTS THAT
WAY, BECAUSE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US,
GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
ISSUES WE DISCUSSED TODAY AND
HAVE THROUGHOUT OUR ENTIRE
HEARING. SO WITH THAT, WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. THE SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE, ONE ON EDUCATION,
STANDS ADJOURNED